Welcome back, master and mistress!
I was just in a lobby with everybody.
And then, Rando started joining.
Doki was like, huh?
And we were like, hello?
And then, they were like, you shouldn't be in here.
And then, they were like, it's a public lobby.
So, I'm not in a room with anybody anymore.
That was funny.
Doki all of a sudden was like, who the hell is this person?
And then they were like, it's a public lobby.
Oh my gosh.
That was so funny.
I think everybody is kind of getting set up.
Hi, guys.
Hello.
Here we are in a room with us.
Today, I'm L.
I don't really know anything about...
About Death Note, but I just thought this face was too good.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, we have to wait for maintenance.
What is happening?
I'm L.
So, this game just came out today.
It's basically... It's like Among Us, but Death Note.
So, that's kind of fun.
Baby face.
Why do we always choose Tuesdays?
Why do we always choose Tuesdays for collabs?
It's a Steam maintenance, so...
I guess we'll just hang together until...
Until things are fine, I guess.
Because Garfield hates Mondays.
Oh, it's like 5 to 10 minutes long.
That's not bad.
We're just chilling.
I hope you guys are having a good day.
Jumpscare.
Is it maintenance time for Limelight?
Yeah.
Doki says she's explaining the rules to my chat.
Well, okay.
I'll do that too.
I'll be productive.
I'll explain.
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys the rules.
I don't know how to play.
I did the tutorial.
What's training?
Oh, I think this is the tutorial.
I did it, but only for the investigator.
Okay, so you have the investigator.
Which are literally just the cops.
And then you have L, which is the main investigator.
And gives orders to investigators.
Hot dog.
Cute ghost made jumpscare.
And then you have Misa.
Oh, sorry.
You have Kira's follower.
Only one.
Kira really fell off.
The guy only has one follower.
And they steal investigator IDs for Kira.
And...
Maybe I should do the tutorial.
Because I'm just reading it.
Wait.
Steal investigator IDs...
Wait, no.
Oh my gosh.
Steal their IDs before they trademark them.
Steal investigator IDs for Kira and report those.
Making frequent contact with others.
Oh my gosh.
You have to report anybody who is social.
Being arrested while holding an ID will result in your removal from the game.
Oh my gosh.
She's stealing IDs.
And then of course you can be Kira.
Use the death note to judge those whose true names are known.
So you steal the IDs so that you can get the true name.
And then you can kill people.
Isn't that exciting?
Oh my gosh.
A little time to intro chat.
The fact that it says your ID may have been stolen everytime someone walks up to you freaks me out.
I know.
That's what Vienna was saying.
Sorry, I'm reading the Discord chat.
But yeah, when you walk up to somebody, it'll be like...
Your ID might have been stolen.
It's so freaky.
According to Keikaku.
Do you guys know what Keikaku means?
Do you know?
Do you know what Keikaku means anyway?
Plan!
Keikaku means plan!
Isn't that so exciting?
Who are these bozos?
I don't want to be an investigator at all.
They look so lame.
This guy is so...
What was it?
Doki was saying that these are like the puppets that someone uses.
Is it this guy in here?
Hot dog!
Keikaku means hot dog.
Limo's Steam is back.
There is also...
The reason you might be wondering why aren't we in a group chat, a group call together or whatever.
There's in-game...
There's in-game voice.
So, we'll use that.
And I prefer that so much more because it kind of helps the chaos a little bit.
Do you guys want to see my character?
You have to pay for these ones.
Oh my god.
You have to pay for these ones, but this is my lady.
Looks just like me.
Yeah, I paid for these accessories.
But you have to pay... Oh my gosh, I want this guy.
Oh, it's Mello.
Mello looks a little bit different.
Can be unlocked via customization track volume 1.
Oh, I have to pay for him too?
Oh my gosh.
Misa with the party is so cute though.
And look, there's like headwear.
But of course I gotta be this hat.
Gotta be the clown, I paid for it.
I paid for the clown, I gotta use it.
What?
Like a baby little santa?
A nurse?
The eyes are so freaky in this game.
They are so... They are so freaky.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I want the... I want the nose.
Back.
Oh my... I didn't realize I had wings.
Nevermind.
Rem's wings.
Wow, I need that.
Wait, I could just carry... Oh, no, no, no.
I could just carry the death note with me?
That's kind of freaky.
Okay, confirm.
Nice.
Okay, Doki should maybe invite us soon.
I think.
Is this a kuso game?
I don't think so.
I think it's a legit game.
I think.
It just came out.
So we'll find out today.
Did you know this game was supposed to be Resident Evil 4 and Light Yagami was going to replace Leon Kennedy?
Wow, they didn't go for it.
That's crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Amelie is like, I changed my name back to Have Mercy Daddy.
Don't be alarmed.
Chat rioted.
And then Doki is just like, why is Bao playing web fishing?
What does level 1 out of 40 mean?
Oh, you can unlock things.
Look at this.
We can get more... These are how you unlock the customizable things, but then these are the paid ones.
What are these?
I want the randoserudo.
Oh my gosh, sexy time.
Wait, these ones are kind of awesome.
Doki paid to become the Bishounen, but I wanted to be the little freaked out one.
Wait, I have to pay to get the Chuni eye patch?
No!
Why are these dot dot dots?
What does that mean?
I want the randoseru.
You have to choose between them, but I think eventually, the more you level up, you eventually get all of them.
Right, they seem to repeat.
They seem to repeat.
Oh wait, I didn't choose one.
You guys, which one should I choose?
Should I be L?
Wait, I have this on my profile head, don't I?
Wait, not my profile...
Should I be L?
Misa is kind of freaky too, though.
Wait, we can see the details.
It's hideous.
It looks like a horrible baby.
It looks like the ugliest baby I've ever seen in my life.
My afterlife.
Oh my gosh, she hasn't slept in years.
I think it's the lack of eyebrows.
Lack of... Oh gosh, it's just...
Oh my gosh, let's go with L.
Yay!
Oh my gosh, we can be... Wait.
This is the only thing I bought.
Even though, I think it looks better without... Even though I paid for the eye mask, I think it looks better without it.
I think it looks better without it.
The eyes are so far... It's so hideous.
It's so ugly.
Oh, just sent invites again.
I didn't get one.
I didn't get one, Doki.
Doki, I didn't get one.
I didn't get one.
Is this a sponsored stream?
No.
Would like to know if it's worth downloading.
I mean, you can watch it and then...
I haven't played it, so... I mean, if you... I might have a different opinion than you, though.
If you're just like, not my style.
Then, you know, whatever.
I think Steam is still weird.
Super cool the devs collabed with you.
I'm impressed they got the details on your... Hey, on my clown wig.
Hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Does it have single player?
It's... Oh, there it is.
It's minimum four players.
Wait, my invite is weird.
Same as Lime for me.
I got it, but it won't let me take the invite.
Steam invite scared you?
Yeah, I think it's like Among Us.
Toki having Steam issues?
I think we all are.
I think we all are having issues.
It's okay.
It's all good.
I'm just chilling.
How are you guys today?
How sponsored is this stream?
This stream is sponsored by you, the viewer.
And Gamersubs, code Boomer for 10% off your order.
This stream is sponsored by viewers like you.
Skip it.
But if I got a Gamersubs cup...
Would you get it?
You don't have to if you don't want to.
Sure.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me.
I never took out my money from Gamersubs.
I need to deposit that.
I never have since I've started.
Oopsie.
Let me see if it works.
Oh, I can play now.
Let's go.
Hello?
It's not me.
I knew it.
I knew it's not me.
What do you mean it's not you?
It's not me.
I knew I wasn't the issue.
But you're different now.
Hello, you did it.
You did it.
We did it.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna start inviting more people.
Okay, there is push to talk too, so I can talk to you guys still a little bit.
I love that you always choose Tuesdays.
I know.
I'll just keep happening.
Oh, wait, I'm not...
I wasn't...
How do I turn off... I had the push to talk turned off.
Now I don't know how.
It's V.
It's V, yeah, yeah.
If you wanna...
Yeah, but I had it where I didn't have to press it at first.
Oh, you go to settings and then you go to...
It's at the audio.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna turn that off too.
Hello?
I have proximity chat.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, we got you.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Okay, I'm turning up.
Oh my god.
Pay to win.
Let's go.
Okay, like...
You guys invite people or only...
Only I can... Is it only I can invite people or can you guys invite people too?
I don't know.
Let me see.
Is there a way to make it push to talk instead of like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go to settings and you click sound.
I'm on... I'm not on push to talk right now because we're setting up.
I don't think you can change it.
Yeah, I'll up the game a little bit.
I think I have to go to settings.
Oh, wait, here.
Settings, settings.
Oh, there you go!
We got Limu!
Oh my god, we got L!
Okay, Limu is definitely an L.
Okay, we're good.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, I'm L.
Yes, I am!
You're enjoying the fucking game and I get called a fucking nerd.
I'm L!
What are you talking about?
Guys, this is a dollar store L right here.
I'm L right now!
This is like bootleg L, right?
I'm literally L!
It's on my shirt!
It's literally on my t-shirt!
You look great.
You look like you took a soccer ball to the face.
No, I look like I got stung by some bees.
I'm having an allergic reaction.
Those dogs that got stung by bees and stuff?
Yeah, yeah.
It looks like you.
Okay, let me see who else I have.
It's kind of like if L started aging and then got into denial and just got way too much Botox over it.
Oh, no.
Too much fillers inflating my face.
Oh my god, you went to the wrong plastic surgeon, that's for sure.
Question, would this game not let anybody else have like... it wouldn't let me use the name Monarch.
Oh, really?
I don't know.
Like, you're not allowed to use that name.
And I went, huh?
That's weird.
Yeah, it was weird.
Yeah, I have like...
I don't know, maybe... I don't know if like...
I think these names... Maybe somebody else already named themselves Monarch.
I think these names are like... claimed.
You can claim names here.
Oh, I think so too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So there's actual usernames here.
Honestly, some of these avatars look like dolls in like a Chucky movie or something.
It's actually horrifying.
I fucking hate it.
He uses these puppets.
They're ugly, but like...
Ugly.
But he's an orphan, so like, it's excused.
Wait, who made these?
Who?
What?
N, Nier.
Oh, Nier.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, the L successor.
That's the blonde one, right?
The little guy.
No, that's Mello.
Oh.
That's Mello.
It's like the ones that people care less about when they jump the shark.
Wait, so he's the white haired one?
Yeah, he's the white haired one.
Oh my god, you gotta get your weeb card.
I literally um-atched you in anime lore.
That's so sad.
Look, I just got stung by 10,000 bees, okay?
My brain...
You let me um-atch you.
You just got out of the ER.
Yeah, I'm going through it, okay?
Do the doctors give you that little like, party thing?
Where they're like, oh, you did such a good job.
Here's a little toy.
I look like someone's... I look like someone's Gaia Online avatar.
I don't think I have Giga on Steam.
I think I added her, but I don't think she accepted it yet.
Let's see...
I invited her, but she's offline.
Whoa!
Yo, what the hell?
Yo, you wanna change it right?
Mike, what the?
I fucked Mike, oh god.
What was that?
Was that a bow?
Can we get a fucking, uh...
It's just static.
Oh no.
Is it better now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but you gotta up your volume more.
I liked it though.
Turn it back, I could feel it in my teeth.
It's very nostalgic.
Yeah, it's like going to one of those old static TVs and opening your mouth right next to it.
I can even hear static.
Someone's connecting to dial-up right now.
Oh, wait, I think that's... wait, is it Juniper?
Is Juniper dial-up?
It should be.
Up my mic volume.
Wait, I'll mute, I'll mute.
No, okay, you're good, you're good.
You're okay, Juniper, you're okay.
You're not static.
Everyone talk one at a time so we can, like, single out the person.
Uh, Snuffy said... Snuffy said she wants an invite.
She needs an invite.
Oh, okay, I'll get her in.
Testing, testing.
She has to be online.
How's my volume?
Your volume's good.
Oh my god.
I love this con lobby.
We didn't Discord Nitro Boost this, we didn't.
Is it worse?
Hi, hi!
Hello!
Oh, Snuffy, you look great.
Oh my god, you guys look fantastic.
Okay, who didn't do the tutorial?
Who didn't?
I didn't do the tutorial.
I'll give you guys a quick rundown.
Okay, so it's 5v5.
So, like, there's only one L and one Kira.
So you either win by completing tasks as L or Kira or you kill L or you capture Kira.
And as Kira, Kira and Kira followers, you can talk to each other with a transmitter.
So, like, we can, like, secretly talk to each other.
So we're all investigators trying to find out who is Kira and who is Kira followers.
And if you're Kira, if you think you're getting sussed out, you can give your notebooks to other Kira followers so they become Kira.
So, um, and then when you're calling people out as a suspect during the meeting room phase, the L has to give the items to, like, another investigator.
But that investigator could be a Kira follower.
So if you give the suspect items to a Kira follower accidentally, then the suspect is not arrested.
I see.
It's like, yeah, so it's like, yeah.
So...
And then Kira followers and Kiras can steal your IDs by standing next to them.
And I can steal your ID and then we write down your name and you die.
So, you know, if I suddenly stand next to somebody and you're like, what the fuck are you standing next to me for?
They might be trying to steal your ID.
And then, yeah, so this one...
Please!
I was trying to...
How did you guys get all these customized things?
I mean, we all wailed already.
You get a key and then be like, please wait a moment.
Oh my god.
I will be the god of this new world.
I would say that there is, like, when the Kira people go near you or anyone goes near you, it'll warn you saying your ID was stolen, but it doesn't mean they did steal it.
You're just supposed to put in your journal that that person was close enough to you to potentially steal it.
Yeah, so they don't actually steal it, but...
I think it would have been really funny if you hadn't clarified that and then people start screaming at each other.
That's what I was worried about, honestly.
So you gotta be like, I'll be the god of this new world.
I'll be the god of...
Wait, how do you have the subtitles?
Oh, you go to T.
Justice plan.
You're supposed to be the furthest through the menu you go.
The first menu is relatively useful stuff, and then it's player callouts, and then it's like, I will be the god of this new world.
It's so funny.
I don't understand what's going on.
God.
Dead.
Wait, are we missing someone?
Yeah, we're missing Giga.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say.
She said she was going to pee, so maybe she fell in.
I don't think she's okay in the bathroom.
Is there like a Giga update?
Is she like, is she been gone on her stream for too long?
I am becoming a player.
I like how you can just tell people to leave.
Like, actually, please leave.
Please become a player.
That's worse than asking if you're AFK.
Just like...
Oh my god.
Let me adjust my volume just a little bit.
Let's see.
I am going to refill my water while we wait for Giga.
Yeah, we're...
Oh, she's still AFK.
Apparently, people are saying that she's still AFK on Steam.
I don't think she's okay in the bathroom right now.
There's a battle going on in there.
She mainly ran out of toilet paper.
Oh no, somebody help her.
She has nobody.
She's clawing at the door.
Wait, wait, a message.
A DM.
A message.
She's clawing at the door.
She's on pause.
She's in contact.
We're just here shitposting.
Oh my god.
That's a real battle.
You can't beat the game.
God.
Just God.
Only one word.
God.
I need you guys to make sure that all of your audios is good because I'm cooking something.
Okay.
I don't know how it'll go, but I think it's great.
Alright, are we all ready?
Giga's here.
Giga, can you say something so we can hear you?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah, we can hear you.
Giga, were you okay in the bathroom?
Oh yeah, I sat in there for three years.
Alright, are you guys all ready?
Yeah.
I'm starting the game now.
We can still talk in the loading screen.
Oh, we can say what role we want.
I like that.
I'm not gonna be Kira.
I'm not Kira.
Neither am I.
Who could it be?
I'm not Kira.
It must be randomized, that's interesting.
Oh my god, who's gonna be Kira?
Oh my god, Kira followers can't be arrested if they don't have a...
Oh my god.
Ah, man.
Oh, okay.
Whoa, wind conditions.
Can't tell how much they can hear me right now.
Hello?
Who's next?
Oh, hi!
Hi.
Is there push to talk?
Oh gosh, yeah, it's V.
Oh, did you steal my ID?
Hey, wait, how do I do this?
Oh, I have to go monitor somebody.
Excuse me, see ya.
I'm monitoring.
Oh.
Don't trust investigators who try to get close to you or have a notebook open.
Oh, okay.
I look so stupid walking around town.
Oh, hi!
Oh, hello.
Hello, what are you guys doing?
Oh, someone's approaching.
Where are you guys going?
I'm running you guys down in my notebook.
Bella's not talking to me and she's scaring me.
Oh, don't, get away from me, get away from me.
Alima, you're muted.
Okay.
You okay?
Oh no, I'm muted?
Oh, there you go.
No, you're not muted.
Oh, nevermind, okay.
Oh, stay away from me.
Bella's not responding to me, it's creeping me out.
Oh gosh, wait, don't take my ID.
What am I supposed to do here?
Leave a note, but I don't know what note am I leaving.
Hello?
I hear you guys.
What am I doing?
Dude, who keeps stealing my ID?
I don't have that many.
Oh.
Alright, Giga, you're up.
Okay, what's up?
Give.
What's happening?
What happened?
What's going on?
Progress report?
Oh god.
Oh my god.
What happened today?
I failed everything?
Oh my god, that was something.
I should've...
I should've done a lot.
I need to frame what happened.
Okay, okay, nice.
Investigator.
Investigation versus gold.
Uh oh.
Okay, so...
Someone died?
Criminals dead.
Yeah, criminals.
Uh oh.
We're even.
Oh my god, we're even, yeah.
That's fine.
Where is everybody?
Speak up if you're...
How do I know if my ID was taken?
I forgot it at home.
My ID was taken.
My ID...
I think I dropped it.
In the bathroom.
In the toilet.
That's entirely my vibes.
Be insanely rancid.
Wait, is it supposed to be in my inventory?
I think mint.
Mint!
Because as soon as I passed you, I got a notification that someone yoinked my ID.
No, that's just the automatic thing, I think.
It says your ID may have been stolen.
Okay, because Lyne said that, I'm gonna vote for her too.
I have to follow it.
The real Kira knew I would say that, and so they made an arbitrary rule.
I have a question.
How the fuck am I supposed to investigate other players?
Because I failed my investigation of another player.
Can you, like, retract your, like...
What happens if you shamelessly point fingers?
Well, they get arrested.
So, like, they basically...
Oh, they get tied to you.
So we should...
If you want to, like, set somebody up, they get, like, handcuffed to the person that got set up.
I don't want that.
I have a question.
Wait, I have a question.
Who is Kira?
Just...
Great question.
The real Kira would be handcuffed right now.
I want to say I think Mint and Amelie are both suspicious.
I'm suspicious?
I'm just an investigator.
Nobody will be suspicious yet.
Nobody has any fucking clue what we're doing.
The thing is, obviously, to stand next to somebody playing innocent to the most obvious tool tips.
Because I saw Bao voted for you, and Bao seems to know what she's doing.
They're not Kira.
I sure do.
That's what Kira would say.
Wait, you can skip...
I'm gonna vote for that outfit, not gonna lie.
Look at that.
Look at that wig.
Yeah, Mint.
You're hating on me because I'm styling?
That's so messed up.
Mint is, like, impersonating us.
Doing trick shots on us.
Oh, wait, lots of people are voting for me.
This is kind of crazy.
Am I gonna die?
Who are you voting for?
No, you just get handcuffed.
Nobody.
And every day we don't vote is another death on our hands.
Shut up!
I can't take it anymore.
No one was arrested.
Why are we in class?
What is this?
Okay, question that NPCs.
Where's the NPCs?
Hey, stay away from me.
Why do you have three of those in your mouth?
Hey, stay away from me!
You're trying to steal!
Oh my god, Giga's trying to steal my wallet!
Giga's a thief!
Giga's trying to steal my wallet!
I'm gonna steal everyone's wallets!
Oh my god.
Oh, is this a guy?
How do I do this?
Did your wallet get stolen?
No, I think I'm okay.
How do I do the NPCs?
I think I did it.
Oh, I got it.
Okay, nice.
Oh, there's a lot of NPCs.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
What is happening?
What's going on, dude?
That was fast.
How did that happen?
Who was curious?
Oh my god!
We were supposed to protect L!
How did you know?
It's over, dude.
It's over.
Wait, Vienna, how did you do it?
How did they know?
They're too good.
Vienna, how did you know, Vienna?
Vienna is muted.
We have a mastermind in here.
She's so good, she won't even share her secret.
She won't even tell us.
She's like, I don't reveal secrets.
Vienna did the tutorial.
The skill discrepancy, I need a handicap.
We were muted, oh no!
We're getting DMs from her.
I just hear, I hear like some...
Wait, Vienna, change your, change your audio source.
That might be the wrong one.
Select it in the settings.
Okay, yeah.
She's trying to communicate.
There's a mosquito in the lobby.
She's communicating from the beyond.
She can sense L's electrical signal using her electrical telepathic ability.
That's incredible.
Magnetism waves coming from L's transmission.
If you're in the room with us, please make your presence known.
I have his laptop right here.
If you want to talk to L, come here.
I am L, stop impersonating me.
It's so confusing that there's like, Limu is just L, so I'm like, wait, is Limu L or is Limu evil?
When it came up and was like, L has been killed, I was like, oh no, not me.
Oh no, it's not me.
Hold it.
Oh, hold it, hold it and talk.
Oh, that works.
She was talking earlier.
It's Morse code.
Morse code.
I just want to know how she did it.
How did she do it?
I want to know her secrets.
Vianna is going to have superpowers because Vianna was actually playing the tutorials and stuff before we started.
And is like one of the only people that did that.
She went non-verbal to ingest all the information.
I played the tutorials.
I should have done that.
Oh no, that's her gopher.
I sabotaged her so she couldn't explain anything.
She was like, I'm going to play the game.
The real Death Note.
How the fuck do you monitor other players?
I go to cutthroats and go to cut-ins and you see last words.
I got one that was like, I'll post your name on the internet.
I think if you're arrested, that's what you say.
Oh my god.
I love that.
That's dramatic.
I'm going to post your information.
I'll post your name on the internet.
Can I be your girlfriend?
I would.
Want to go for a drink after this?
Why am I rising up?
There's one last word that's like, kill me.
Just kill me.
There's one for El that says, am I a freak?
Am I a freak?
I see me in the mirror every morning.
Oh my gosh, these nameplates are so...
Are your guys' sounds in English or Japanese?
Does it change if you have the English audio?
It's in Japanese only, I think.
Oh yeah, we found out that this game is not available in Japan.
Yeah.
Really?
Is it in Japanese?
Yeah.
I asked Kenya if she wanted to join and she was like, the game's not available for me.
Oh my god, that was bad.
You know how many games I've tried to play with her and she's like, I can't play it because I'm in Japan.
That's so sad.
Why is it reason exclusive when it's literally Death Note?
I don't know.
In Japanese too, like the Japanese audio.
Death in Japan debuff.
Oh my god, I guess they don't want to play Among Us.
It's for us weebs, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, only it's Nostalgia Bay for us.
Oh yeah.
I always wanted to be Kira.
Vienna's restarting the game.
I like how she tried to tell us a couple of times and it was just...
I think I'm starting to understand.
You guys won with her being completely silent, which is crazy.
Yeah, can't Kira like coordinate between all of you guys and like talk to you and like secretly...
Yeah, that's what we were doing.
We weren't that much earlier.
We were like talking to each other.
That's so cool.
That's me.
I was L and I was like...
I am Kira from the great beyond.
Wait, do you actually talk over like a loudspeaker?
Like everyone hears you?
No, only the good team or the bad team hears you.
So Kira can only talk to the killer people, the Kira-aligned people, and L can talk to the investigators.
I was L and I knew how to look through the camera so I was able to like see those.
But I don't know how to talk to everyone.
I don't know how to do it.
No, I think two wasn't...
I mean, we literally got...
Can you hear me now?
We're either Kira or L.
Oh my god.
Yay!
Welcome.
I stole Giga's ID and then wrote her name in the book and she was L, so we won.
Masterful game.
Easy.
This is so easy.
People are just gonna spend the entire time sprinting away from each other.
I find it funny that like anybody who like... it's like COVID.
Anybody who gets like so much close to me, I'm just like, you're fucking dead.
It's chill if I write her name down, right?
It's chill.
So it was just a lucky guess?
Yeah, it was just lucky.
Yeah, based on what you said.
So like there's tasks where like investigators have to be next to a person.
So an investigator could be next to a person just investigating them.
So it throws you off.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah.
Let's do it again.
No idea what I'm doing.
Wait, was that Fiona?
Fiona?
What?
Am I good?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
I wanna be a hot girl.
I'm not Kira this time.
Wanna be Misa?
Yeah, I wanna be a goddess girl.
Being Kira is like stressful, Loki.
First thing I did was give the book to Loki.
Here we go.
Am I gonna be a hot girl?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, come on.
I just wanna be a hot girl.
Okay, it's hard to get the investigation progress, I feel.
I'm here.
I'm ready.
I'm a hot investigator.
Oh, hi, Doki.
Oh, hey.
Hi.
Are you... What are you?
I'm a hot investigator too.
I doubt that.
Oh yeah, I'm gonna write your name.
Get away from me.
No.
Wait, what's happening?
What's happening?
Death note test.
Death note test?
Oh no.
Oh my God, wait.
What?
What the?
What am I doing over here?
A body was found?
Hey, are you the death note...
Oh my God.
Hello?
In here?
Oh, what is happening?
Dude, everyone... A bunch of people dead.
Oh shit.
This is... This looks dangerous.
We have 16 seconds left.
Oh gosh, we're not gonna make it.
We're not gonna make it.
What's happening?
People are dead everywhere.
In here?
How do I go over here?
I think here.
Oh my God.
Hello.
I took a note.
You're supposed to resolve those in time.
That was like really fast.
I know.
We had no time at all.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I said.
OK.
Back to our normal schedule.
Ignore the dead people.
Who cares?
Yeah, ignore the dead people.
I don't need to talk to this bozo.
I need to talk to this bozo.
Oh my gosh, they were in here the whole time.
Oh, who the hell was that?
Hello?
Limel?
What did you just do?
I gave you a thing.
I don't know why.
Oh, you gave me a lost item.
OK.
Thank you.
Mint.
I have a lost item for you.
People keep giving me lost items.
Lost item?
I don't know what it means.
I don't have any items on me.
So I don't actually know how to do this.
Where's Limel?
I don't know how this game works.
OK.
Thanks.
I think.
What's going on?
WD.
Nice.
Supposedly someone was talking on a transceiver during the night.
Oh wait, we only have 7 seconds left in the day.
Oh no!
Snuffy!
Snuffy, what were you doing?
I was reading my notebook.
Is it possibly a black notebook?
It was my investigation notebook.
Why did you walk so close to me?
I have some hot news.
We were resolving the thing and Mint talked to us but didn't help resolve the thing.
I didn't know how to.
You know what?
That's a very lucky story.
Doki, you literally just said you saw Snuffy with the book.
Why are we ignoring you?
There's a Kira follower.
Wait, my ID was stolen.
My ID was stolen too.
Yeah, everyone stole my ID.
Everybody approached me.
This sucks.
I think it's Snuffy because I saw her bring out the notebook in the corner as if she was hiding something.
Everybody has a notebook.
Was it the investigation notebook ad?
No, I saw it was a black notebook.
My ID got stolen and Jupi and Giga were close to me at suspicious moments.
Yeah, you would say that, wouldn't you, Kira?
I was running past Vienna and then as soon as Vienna saw me run past her, she immediately turned and was following after me and was like, I'm supposed to investigate you, but I don't know.
No, but Vienna was definitely resolving the dead person with me, so...
Okay, fair.
I was resolving the last body by myself because Mint walked away.
No, I came up and it finished.
We ran out of time.
Why are you suspecting me?
You literally saw Snuffy.
There's still a follower out there.
We gotta get all of them and I remember before she was like, I wanna be just like Misa.
My ID was stolen.
My social security is on the line right now.
Wait, we're just dead if we don't get the person.
I think there's more to worry about than your social security if it got stolen.
I'm gonna vote for Limu because you had a little magnifying glass after you walked by me, you were looking at my ID.
I returned your lost property.
It said Mint has lost an item and I was like, oh, that sucks.
I lost nothing!
So I went and got it and I gave it to you.
Your notebook?
Oh, I lost my ID, that's right.
Is it in your bag now?
Because I gave you an item and I got experience for doing it.
No, I have no items.
I also had a prompt to deliver Mint a lost item, but I don't know how.
Everybody has my ID apparently.
How did so many people return it just to lose it again?
Are we voting Snuffy then?
I voted for Snuffy.
Change to Snuffy who hasn't voted.
That's so sad.
What if like the investigation notepad is just like everyone's is the same like color?
Now what?
Oh wait, who was gonna confiscate the item?
You can trust me.
No, don't give it to Doki.
What do you mean?
I'm the one that called her out.
Who is this?
Is it Snuffy?
One giant handcuff.
Why are they zooming in on the face?
They are publishing the name.
Live reactions.
Oh yeah.
We won!
We did it!
I'll add more Akira followers.
Really?
You can do that?
Yeah, I can increase it.
Oh, I got a last word.
My apologies, Snuffy.
I wasn't good enough.
It was the first time trying to figure it out.
I didn't know it would just be so obvious.
I tried to hide in the corner and like away from the camera.
It's just like it's so obvious if you're looking at it.
You have to do like the same like button thing.
I thought maybe I would just have to click on something, but you have to do like a button combo thingy.
So just like if you want to go kill somebody, make sure you're like ready to do like a quick button press.
QTE that shit.
I feel like the map isn't big enough.
Like we are always bumping into each other.
I think there is a different map.
I don't know if there's a different map now.
I'm checking the settings right now.
Wait, what happened at the first part with the body thing?
What even was that?
I didn't make it to any of those.
I don't know.
What the fuck was happening?
It was like a bunch of crimes, but the amount of time we had to resolve the crimes was fucking minuscule.
So it was like impossible to do.
Can they do that?
Because I don't remember that from the tutorial.
Every player has black notebooks.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah.
All players have black notebooks.
We totally know how to play this game, so that will just make it really easy to learn.
I mean, it's okay.
We're still figuring it out.
I'm sure after like a round or two, we'll get the hang of it.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Let's see...
It's 1-1 right now for bad and good guys.
I'm gonna turn down the meeting hours, so less discussion.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Question, does the notebooks look different than the Death Note?
If they do, they won't.
Not anymore.
Not anymore, I made it so they're all black.
Yeah, they're all gonna be the same.
Yeah, so we take our notebooks out, it's gonna be like black, so we don't know if it's an actual Death Note or not.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna check if there's other settings.
Is there a way to increase the time for the sabotage, whatever happens?
The sabotage?
A round increase would be good.
A round increase time would be nice.
Yeah, that too.
Okay, increasing the round.
Uh...
Day-night?
I think that's it.
I'll do 90 seconds.
Okay, let's try it.
90 seconds and then... I'm checking if there's anything else.
Uh... I think we can do that for now and then we'll adjust the settings later.
Uh-huh.
Alright, starting now.
Let's go.
Sexy.
Oh, I could... Oh, I can turn off role selection next game.
Oh, wait.
I don't think it matters though, because every time I've pressed Kira follower, nothing happens.
This is what you want, but it won't always give it to you, I guess?
Oh, I never pressed confirm.
Oh my god.
Oh, come on.
It still didn't work.
This sucks.
Oh, come on.
It's because I'm dressed up as L.
The desire meter.
What's the hint?
I'm running around.
I'm a little investigator doing investigating things.
Limu is very sussy right now, just following me.
Let's do this guy.
Oh, hello.
What's my task?
Oh, okay.
I'm avoiding.
This guy is suss... Oh, never mind.
Hello, Limu.
Excuse me.
Fancy seeing you here.
One person came by today.
It was Limu.
That was me.
Oh, I completed my tasks.
Okay.
I'm gonna explore now.
Oh, look at the giant cake.
Wow.
Pop a coin.
Thanks for six months.
Thank you.
This is death note among us.
Yeah, actually.
What?
How did you get that?
What the...
I don't hear her anymore.
Anybody in here?
Okay, let's go looking.
L.
Vindicating evidence.
Investigating my contact.
What is this?
Oh, what is this?
Limu's role is investigator.
Oh, there's more... Okay, there's more tasks at night.
Oh, that's kind of fun though.
Okay, so...
Is Kira gonna kill me too?
So it makes it so when you finish your day tasks...
There we go.
Two people.
Oh, finish all your canvas tasks for the day.
I gotta go monitor the parking lot.
So Limu is safe.
I figured.
Oh my gosh.
I'm scared of you guys.
What's going on in here?
What are you doing here?
It's funny finding you here in the garage.
Yeah, funny finding you here, little lady.
Now, why would you walk in if you knew that I walked in here, but there's nothing in here?
I walked in here not knowing you walked in here.
But I just saw you outside, so you walked in behind me.
I saw no one walk through here.
I was running away from others.
Hmm.
Wow, suspicious.
Why are you in here when there's no car here?
You have no car, no business.
Because I don't know this map.
Quite suspicious.
I'll be posting this on the internet.
You ain't gotta do all that.
Oh my god!
What the hell?
Did this happen the first time?
Oh my god!
No!
Oh my god.
She's the only one who knew.
Okay, who specified that she had such a horrible death?
You could've just been like...
She's gonna post her names on the internet.
I was like using Lime for standing too close to me, and then the next second a car hit her.
We literally saw that she's an investigator.
We literally had her confirmed.
Maybe you were her in the notebook.
I believe she got isekai'd.
A dying message.
My ID was stolen.
I don't know who it was.
That'll do it, bro.
Wait a minute, my thing says, Amelie seems to have been in close contact with many people, so they might be L.
Be sure to tell them.
Okay, me and Bao were next to Lime when she got hit by the car.
Did that literally happen?
My passport was...
Who was next to me?
Somebody stood next to me and I was like, that'd be funny if they took my ID.
And they did!
Who was it?
That's your fault, you need to pay attention.
Wait, I don't have an ID either.
Wait, I think it was Vienna.
I saw someone right in a notebook right before that happened on the left side of the map.
I was watching Joopi.
My notebook out.
That was like a heart attack, because everybody pulls out the death.
That's really scary.
That's very specific.
I think Juniper would do something that specific.
I wouldn't do something... I never do specific things.
I like to do...
Okay, buddy.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
Oh my god, somebody actually died and now we're not like, accusing somebody right away.
I'm really... I don't care.
I don't need to accuse somebody.
No one was arrested.
Oh, Lima.
She was right here with me.
How do I... What does it look like?
Oh, now I have my notebook open.
Okay.
So I'm like, making investigations.
No one's been here by...
So, I kind of get it.
So if someone looks like they're...
Investigating a person...
But then the person says no one's been here, then you can kind of tell.
I get it.
I get... You can...
Oh, set up surveillance.
Okay.
Oh, what do I do?
I got a thing.
Okay, I'm about to install it.
In here.
I'm doing it.
I installed it.
I did my part.
I'm starting to understand.
Because I'm like, how are you supposed to tell...
When someone has been...
Like, you know, if someone's not doing their tasks.
Oh, hi.
Hello.
Interesting.
Oh my gosh!
Did you steal my ID?
I didn't take your ID.
I need to observe you.
Wait, you need to observe me?
Are you taking my ID?
Oh my gosh!
I'm about to die.
Oh no!
Oh gosh.
What am I doing?
I'm resolving the incident.
One person resolving.
Hey, why... Okay, two people.
Yeah, it's us.
What the hell is this?
Yeah.
A mime has died.
Probably.
Okay, so we got that one.
Nice.
Wait, there was three people in here.
Why did only two help?
I see.
Unlikely story.
Yeah.
Oh.
More NPCs.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm gonna go see if this one...
This one might say something about...
Oh.
Grimmy.
Someone talking on a transceiver.
Don't kill me.
Come here, Grimmy.
Loyalty to the mission, Grimmy.
No, no, no, no.
Wait, where is this person?
In here?
I'm not good at these.
At the cafe.
These little notes are not very helpful.
Hello.
Oh, excuse me.
Someone might have stolen my ID.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna hide here.
And be on my book.
I'm gonna make it look really sussy.
Like I'm killing someone.
I'm killing someone in my book.
Amelie's sus?
I don't think so.
No.
No!
I got death-soded.
Who?
Who is that?
Sorry, someone's a mosquito again.
Oh, is it me?
No.
It only happens for like a second.
I think it's fine.
Oh my god.
He's laughing at me!
Get him, Kira!
Snuffy.
That first round was just a test of your abilities.
I fucking knew it!
I knew it!
This is so funny!
I mean you, Elle.
I think we should vote Snuffy every time.
I said Snuffy!
I called her out!
Snuffy couldn't hear you guys for what it was worth.
Like she said she couldn't hear you.
Oh really?
I was really scared that that was like a feature if I was Kira.
Because like I could only hear when Vienna talked to me over the communications.
But everybody else was dead silent.
I couldn't hear anybody.
Weird.
I don't think that's supposed to happen.
No, that would make it really obvious.
Because people would just walk around being like, can you hear me?
I kept trying to go around being like, I can't hear anybody.
I'm sorry.
But I just was worried that was so obvious.
Yeah, I was like trying to call you out and you wouldn't respond.
Oh, Snuffy said her mic's not working and I realized...
Wait, that would help me as talking to you.
Alright, let's see.
You guys could hear me though, right?
I could hear you fine.
Is that okay?
We're YouTube camping now.
I think it was alright.
Let's see what other stuff I can adjust.
I know we can like do a...
What was it?
You don't have to choose what you want it to be.
Oh yeah, it's just...
Yeah, make it random.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is it though?
I chose follower like investigator and it was just like you.
Actually, I didn't...
No, I picked follower and it made me Kira.
And I was like, what?
I didn't even pick this.
Okay.
No problem, I've done it before.
I wonder if her computer died.
Wait, who?
Who's?
Oh yeah, it said that she left the room.
I feel bad.
Oh wait.
I accused her of being...
Kira got her.
She's gone.
I have to apologize to her.
She has to come back.
Usually for like games like Among Us...
Did you guys hear my epic music though?
Yeah, it was good.
Actually, for games like Among Us, you don't really accuse people like...
When only one person has died.
I have to get out of the maybe Among Us mindset, you know?
Because, you know, the laws of probability...
It's harder.
I feel like Kira has an easier job than the investigators.
Now I'll be a liable partner, you know?
So you'll be like, dang, Snuffy could be L.
Which means she's a big brain and super cool.
Kira could just be lucky.
Yeah, right.
Because I said something only the Shinigami can tell you about Amelie.
And nobody noticed.
I thought literally it's our third game.
I don't think we could...
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure nobody fucking knows.
It's okay.
We're all learning live as we go along.
Be careful if you're the bad guy.
That was okay.
I hope Kira didn't...
I can't... Okay, wait.
Snuffy, so you killed Lime like that?
Yeah.
That's so funny.
How does that feel?
Because I had to investigate her, which meant that I was like cuddling up real close.
Yeah, I think it's definitely...
Kira, Miss, Limes...
A lot of them.
I definitely think it's really hard with... It's like... I don't know how to describe it.
It's really hard with the notebooks or without them.
Because then everybody's pulling out the death note.
And I could probably just kill somebody in front of everybody.
And nobody could ever like question that.
So it kind of adds that like secret...
I'm Kira, so I don't know.
I kind of think that maybe...
It's kind of hard that way too.
So it's something you guys...
I feel like Kira's...
I think you should probably run away or have to hide to do the death noting thing.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, I turned the...
I turned the notebooks back to...
Like Kira.
Only Kira's black notebook then.
Yeah.
Because right now it's kind of like...
Like, Kira can just get lucky.
It feels like a little unbalanced.
Yeah, she just looks at everybody putting out the notebook.
And she's like, I'm gonna write people's names right now in front of everybody.
I was just running around being like, I can't hear anything.
And Vianna would be like, hey, that person's really suspicious.
I think they're...
Apparently...
I was just like...
That would not be...
Whispering in your ear would do nothing.
I'm sorry.
So I guess we'll...
We'll start it off then.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That's so funny, Sophie.
You did everything you did all the way.
Oh, come on.
I'm always investigating.
Ah, okay.
I'll be the best there can be.
I'm a prime.
I'm an investigator in my prime.
I've just started.
I'm just a little investigator.
Hey, Snuffy.
I'm green, but I'm full of hope and ambition and lots of really fun ideas.
Oh, who am I?
Oh, I'm supposed to be observing someone.
Oh, my God.
Who the hell is this?
Oh, God.
Sorry, my bad.
I was...
You're not the person I'm supposed to be.
One person came by.
Okay.
Interesting.
No one's been here before me, eh?
Okay, interesting.
Interesting.
Who am I following?
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Why are you guys kissing?
I have my eye on you and Groomy.
This is my yaoi family.
Doki Doki's trying to mind game me.
I don't like it.
I'm saying that, like, she...
This is the only person I stood next to.
So, like, if something happens, if my ID is gone, I'm just saying...
Okay.
Only person, eh?
Only person, eh, Doki?
I wrote your name down.
Oh,
I gotta go all the way.
Okay, hold on.
This person first.
I'm chatting.
Five people?
Hello?
Six people.
Are they sure about that?
It was you.
ViennaSauce?
Why?
I can't tell...
Oh.
Nah, I know.
Three people came by today.
Hello.
Wait!
I...
I don't know.
I should've been the fourth person.
Hey, what's going on over here?
No, I...
Why would I say three people though?
How would I have known that number?
With the problems, the incidents...
We're resolving?
I'll resolve the incident.
Okay, nice.
Someone might have stolen my ID.
I might be dead.
I might be...
L...
Oh, where is it?
Oh, it's over here!
Oh no!
It's solved!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my God, that was close.
Lucky.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna hide over here and be Kira.
I'm gonna be Kira in this room.
No way.
What are you doing next to me?
What are you...
I'm trying to up my volume.
What are you doing?
Me?
Yeah, what are you doing?
I wasn't next to you.
I was in a storage closet.
Did Kira do anything?
Isn't that good?
Why are we stopping Kira?
Yeah, that's good for Kira.
That's something Kira would say.
What?
Oh my gosh, my ID was stolen!
My ID was stolen!
Oh my God.
There goes my ID.
My ID.
No!
I was gonna say, who was it?
Identity fraud is not a joke.
And it didn't get stolen, so I actually think Mint might be chill.
I am chill.
I had contact with a lot of people today.
I had contact with, I think, Grimmy, Doki, Snuffy, Amelie, and Mint.
So, God fucking knows who it was.
I think it was Doki.
Because Doki's the only person I was next to.
No, you weren't.
I was there.
Don't you worry.
I ran away from you.
No, I was right next to you.
You're the only person I actually went next to.
No fucking way.
Look, okay.
I was next to Lime and Vienna.
My ID is safe.
That sounds like a scam.
I don't hear Lime, so God.
How do I up someone's voice?
Oh, here we go.
Wait, toggle ID, what does that mean?
How do I get out of here?
Alright, we're setting up surveillance.
Surveillance.
I got the surveillance.
Going to set it up.
I'm coming over here.
I'm setting it up.
I set it up.
I'm the master investigator.
I have no idea where to set up the thing.
Wait, no.
Stay away from me.
I gotta get the paper safe.
I gotta keep the paper safe.
Oh my gosh.
S.W.
One person came by today.
I'm the FBI, knock knock.
Oh my God.
I've never been in here before.
I'm gonna chill in here.
I completed all my tasks.
I'm just an investigator.
Of course an investigator would be in the...
Oh my gosh, look at the little poster of Misa.
An investigator would be in the FBI...
In the police office.
Police...
God, I...
What?
God, what?
Your D.O.
is stolen anyway, so it doesn't matter.
No, stop.
Stop.
Stop!
Oh my God!
I have to investigate this person again?
You're not Kira, are you?
What's in here?
Anybody, knock knock.
Police!
What am I doing here?
Oh, I'm investigating.
Investigated properly.
Can you just like talk to random things to make it look like you're doing a task?
No.
Yeah, I think Doki is pretty sus because she has a sword.
I think that.
I think that a lot.
Amelie!
In here, right?
Okay.
Three people came by today.
What if I just stood here with my notebook out?
It would look really suspicious.
Okay, I've had contact.
Oh, got my I.D.
earlier.
Wait!
What's happening?
We're dead.
We're dead!
Oh yeah, I've been dead for a while.
No one's found my body.
No!
Oh yeah.
Did Snuffy get near you?
Maybe.
Okay, I think it could be Giga or Snuffy.
I'm freaking dead.
Oh my god, they did good today.
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
No!
Who is...
What happened?
My god.
Wait, Grimmy died too!
Wait, what?
I think they're seeing your death scene for the first time.
Oh, they're seeing...
No!
How did I die?
Oh my god, our seats are empty.
This is so sad.
That was absolutely not heaven.
That was...
What even happens afterwards?
That's the bonus cutscene.
That reveal left us hanging.
Oh my god!
I like how they didn't kill the criminals, they killed us instead.
Uh oh.
Do you get a new ID every round?
Or once your ID is gone, you're just in danger of getting murdered?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
Speak up if you picked up a dying message.
What does that mean?
Did anyone...
No!
Oh my god, no, I didn't want to press the button!
I think you can get your IDs back if we vote somebody out that might have your ID, we can get it back.
My ID?
Yeah, yeah.
We should need to call somebody out.
Wait, I have a dying message, where do I find it?
Oh, maybe in your investigation notepad?
Oh.
And I still...
Oh, I can see all the roles!
You can see the roles!
I think we need longer to do the voting if we do actually find stuff like that, because it's about to end and we haven't even...
Okay, yeah, we got it.
It didn't even give me a dying message when I voted!
It was random, it was not targeted, I swear.
None of them's a follower.
It was not targeted, I just clicked as close as I could.
It was Snuffy again, I can't believe this.
Holy, we're gaming.
Um, do I just sit here?
Yeah, I think if you go...
If you go to like...
You can...
Monitor another player, I'm watching Snuffy right now.
Wait, if you go to what?
I think it's...
Like, you can select a player with E and then you can watch them run around and do stuff.
Oh, okay.
Oh, she found my body.
Who does she see?
L decoy.
What is going on?
Trying to kill me.
Oh,
no one opens a notebook?
Snuffy's been Kira, like, twice.
She's getting really good at this and none of us know what we're doing.
I know!
None of us know what we're doing!
I need to investigate you.
I need to investigate you first.
Where did you die, Grimmy?
I died in, like, the very bottom quarter.
No one's gonna find my...
Giga actually thought and then left, so I'm pretty sure Giga's the follower.
There, she's doing it again.
She's doing it again.
Snuffy's killing again.
Oh my god.
Snuffy.
Snuffy, don't...
Look at her and her stupid ass L disguise.
Oh my god, she's going into a corner to kill.
Wait, that room has a monitor in it.
Oh my god, she's sending a message.
Kira.
Snuffy, there's a camera out there, don't do...
Yeah, there's a camera in there.
Do it, do it, do it.
Do it, Snuffy, I dare you.
See what happens.
I know, it's actually good, we can kind of monitor the...
The bad guy and learn their ways.
Oh, she's doing it!
Oh my god!
No!
Live!
Why is it always us?
Oh my god, what the...
Oh no,
again?
She's on a spree!
She's on a killing spree!
Oh my god.
Snuffy is so sus.
Be careful!
Doki, sniffer out, sniffer out.
Sniffy.
If you're dead, you can actually see who's role is whose.
If you open up the investigator list and press X, yeah, so...
It's very obvious who it is.
I don't see a follower though.
Oh, let's see.
I only see investigators and...
L, Kira.
Didn't Doki fuck up and accidentally lower the amount of followers?
Oh, maybe.
It's Snuffy versus all of us.
Oh my god.
Snuffy is killing it then.
Literally.
Oh yeah, it's just Snuffy alone.
That's so funny, because Doki was like...
What is Kira doing?
Nothing!
I know!
She's doing the job of two.
It's 1v8.
Don't be fucking doomed though once your ID is stolen.
It's basically just like, guess I'll die when Kira decides it.
Right?
Oh!
Joint investigation.
What does that mean?
But like...
Maybe we shouldn't announce if we got our ID stolen then?
I don't know.
Oh no, we should, because like...
Kira will always know when we have our ID stolen, because they have it now.
Yeah, true, true.
Oh, 7 seconds.
Oh my god.
Snuffy is being so sus.
If you're Kira's helper, you have to physically give the ID.
Oh yeah.
We can finally hear voices.
No!
I have to watch this twice when I die.
That's weird.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh no!
Jiggle investigate.
You're gonna dox.
I have no idea what's going on.
Yeah, that's what a Kira would say.
That's what a Kira would say right there.
I know it looks suspicious, but it's not fair if my game's fucked up.
Just do your tasks!
I think it's Snuffy.
I'm...
I'm Snuffy.
I have no idea what's even going on, so I can't even say like...
Guys, I'm doing my investigations.
Oh my god, all the criminals are dead!
Oh my god.
Wow.
New world progress.
I'm helping with the tasks, but I'm sorry I can't be more verbal with anybody.
Oh!
Oh my god!
That's not good.
Uh oh.
Guys, come on investigators.
We're just almost there.
Everybody's dead!
This is a close one.
Snuffy was alone.
Oh, my idea was stolen?
I know who was next to me.
So it's either Snuffy, Joopy, or Doki.
I know like...
To be fair...
I think this game is saying that if Limu were her...
And Limu died!
I stood next to a lot of people after that.
And then I stood next to...
Come on Doki!
You know it's Snuffy!
She's not!
Sniff her out!
Good point.
Maybe it's Juniper because...
Oh my god, Doki!
Can you help with the investigations?
The two that we did?
I did too.
I did and then I saw Lime.
Because I don't know.
I saw and then I was going to do it.
I saw Lime and...
Oh, they're voting?
I'm going to just fucking...
Collapse.
Oh my god!
It's so over.
They're like, it's Snuffy.
No, it can't be.
Oh my god, she's literally just standing and...
Oh my god!
Doki!
You deserve that.
You honestly deserve that.
Oh my god.
No!
Can you call...
Can you call meetings in this?
I wonder.
I think L can.
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
Wait, who killed you?
Who killed you guys?
What are you talking about?
It's Snuffy.
I'm ready to go.
I told you!
I fucking...
I was like, it has to be Snuffy.
It has to be Snuffy.
The camera's right there.
Nobody believed me.
Oh my god.
Wait, who is...
But...
Juniper is L and there's a...
Snuffy is like killing people right in front of the camera.
And nobody believed me.
I fucking knew it.
I...
I knew it.
I'm gonna fucking pee in anger.
I'll be right back.
Oh wait, they just revealed Vienna's role.
So now everybody will know that it's Snuffy.
I don't think they know that those people are dead though.
Yeah.
True.
They don't see it until the end of the round.
Oh, true.
I think...
Oh no.
This is so bad.
They're not gonna make it.
Oh my gosh.
Stay away.
All she needs is your ID.
I actually wonder if balance wise it's better to have shorter rounds.
Because it feels like it's way too easy to steal everybody's fucking IDs at this point.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
This is stressing me out.
I wish I could move around as a ghost.
I know, you can watch the people but you can't move.
You have to like pick one to spectate.
You open your little investigator list and click on somebody.
Oh, it's literally like...
Wait, it's like they have to just figure out...
Is it just one Kira and then it's Vienna and Juniper against Snuffy?
Yeah, there's no Kira helper for some reason.
Yeah.
Oh, I guess it's like random.
Random.
Oh my god, can you get hit by the car?
What just happened?
Can you imagine after all that Kira gets hit by a car?
Oh my god.
Oh no, she's making her move.
No, no, no, she's investigating.
She's stealing IDs.
This is so bad.
It's not me.
Wait, so the further the days go, do like more events happen?
That's kind of fun.
Yeah, they start saying different things like the witnesses.
Yeah.
Please, please just...
Elle, call a meeting, Elle.
I know, call a meeting.
You know that there's only three of you left.
Who's Elle?
It's uh...
Juniper.
Juniper, yeah.
We're just letting Stuffy do whatever she wants!
God, but she knew I was out there and she took my life!
Are you guys having trouble getting back in, like the invites aren't working?
Can you trace over the invites?
Yeah, I can invite her.
I think we have to be in the lobby again.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, okay.
Fucking knew it.
I knew she wasn't...
I knew she wasn't real.
How does she keep getting Elle though?
I mean Kira, I mean.
I think, I don't know, I think there's just something about her.
It's that stupid Elle costume.
I like it though.
I'll post your names on the internet!
Oh my god, it's you!
Damn, look at him.
It's me.
With your sword!
No!
Juniper, I swear to god.
Oh my god.
One of us is Elle, one of us is Kira, and one of us is like John Adam.
It's Snuffy!
I swear it's Snuffy!
You guys saw that Vienna is... Vienna is an investigator, it's Snuffy!
No, I sucked you two to work together because all three of us were in a room together.
And I was like, this is how I can prove to them that I'm safe!
It's Snuffy!
We did it!
That would be too obvious if you just couldn't pick them.
Then if you tried to assign an investigation to somebody like that, it would just be like, sorry, that guy's evil, you can't pick them.
It happens.
Oh my god.
Snuffy, you are talking so good right now, but I...
I can't say anything because I can't hear anybody, so I'm just...
You are talking so fucking good!
He's using the I can't hear anybody excuse.
I can't hear anyone.
It's a game, it's glitched.
I mean, she legitimately cut him.
Oh my god, here it is.
Sweet justice, sweet justice.
I wish we could hear you during the round.
What, you can't hear me either?
I can't hear anybody and you can't hear me?
You were like running at me.
I was trying to tell Junia how to investigate her.
Ta-da!
How did we win that?
Oh my god.
How did we win?
Why didn't you tell us?
I'm so confused.
There's a maximum amount of people you can kill every day, so I just tried to write everybody's names down.
And I was just like, you can't kill any people until the next day.
So it was basically like me blindly picking because I had nobody to give me like IDs or tell me anything.
Oh my god.
That's so sad.
I think it must be random then.
Maybe.
Both times I can't hear anybody.
So that was genuinely a thing though.
That's weird.
I don't know.
Maybe we...let's send another invite to Val so you can join them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just sent an invite to her.
I just sent it.
That's so weird that you couldn't hear anybody because we could hear you.
We might have to restart the lobby because she got a connection fail.
It says room full.
I think it's because she DC'd.
Restart.
Oh my goodness.
This game is kind of whack.
I think I'm...I still feel it's way more balanced towards Kira still.
It's too difficult to see who's doing the tasks.
You know, like...I rather...I wish it was like more varied tasks where it's not just...
Oh, I'm going to go investigate this person.
I'm going to ask Doki if she can...
Add Doki.
Can you add more tasks?
Because I feel like...
It's like...
With at least like Among Us...
You have various tasks so it's like did someone have garbage?
Oh yeah, I did garbage.
But this one it feels a little more tricky where it's like...
Did you talk to Sakura person?
Yeah, I talked to Sakura person.
Oh, there was no Sakura person...Sakura TV person.
It's weird.
I don't know.
Reading people's inbox.
My bad.
Did it happen again?
It is more complex.
Yeah, it is more complex.
I'm not understanding anything.
That's okay.
It is a silly game though.
I love this outfit.
Can you guys hear me?
We can hear you.
Okay, I'm genuinely wondering...
If you get Kira and you can't hear people...
It seems almost like it's intentional because I can start hearing people almost immediately as voting starts...
But I don't know why it would be the other way around.
Oh, maybe.
I don't know if that's like...
No, no, no, no.
That would be stupid because like...
Then it's really obvious you just woke up to someone and you're like...
Hey, can you hear me?
If they don't respond, it's them.
Yeah, like who's playing completely dumb here and doesn't even understand what's happening?
I think it might have picked your VR headset as a device or something.
You sound like you're in an empty room now.
Yeah.
Oh, maybe it changed.
Maybe it changed though.
Yeah.
I don't know why it says like maximum is one because the literally trailer was like...
You could get up to five followers.
I'm like, what?
You can apparently only have one follower for Kira.
Is that a one or a zero?
Wait, but...
It's only a lobby of ten.
How would you have five followers?
That's insane.
That's much better.
Thank you.
Okay, let's see.
Of course.
I'm doing meeting time longer too.
I know you would tell me if I sounded like shit snuffy, so I'll tell you the same.
I don't have a snuffy girl.
I knew you would want to know.
Yeah, for sure.
I'm going to make it super fast.
Okay.
I'll play your song, I see you.
Oh yeah, and I didn't have a follower that time.
I don't know what happened.
Yeah, because I put random...
I put random and it like makes it so that...
Oh my God, it's completely...
What if nobody got Kira?
Oh my God.
That would be very funny.
I like how at the start of the last round, you sat in front of a camera writing like four names in your fucking notebook.
I know, I noticed that.
I didn't think...
I was like, this game must be like, you know, I don't have a follower.
So I was like, kind of like just fucking around.
You were just like, I'm going to write everybody in.
I know, I just started writing down names like, fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
Who am I missing, guys?
Who am I missing?
Who's missing?
Uh...
Oh guys, it'd be very awkward on the person that...
Juniper!
Oh no, Juniper's right there.
Just kidding.
Amelie!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She has like a weird name.
Was a new invite set.
Oh no!
Amelie is waiting for an invite, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I just forgot she changed her name to the have mercy one.
Okay, oh yeah, I have more tasks too.
Okay, how do I...
Alright.
For which one?
For L and Kira, right?
I think...
Yeah, just more things to do, I think.
Yeah.
I don't know if we wanna...
I don't know if it's worth reducing the amount of time in a day...
Because it feels like most of the IDs can get stolen in one round.
But I don't know.
I'll make it less than, I'll do 60 seconds instead of 90.
Okay.
Yeah, and then we'll see.
I made it super fast.
Actually, no, I shouldn't.
Maybe I'll make us not super fast.
Uh...
More time to talk, for sure.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Day, night, tasks.
I put four tasks.
I'll do four tasks.
And then...
I think that's good, right?
Four tasks.
Or should we add more?
Two was the default.
Four should be fine.
Yeah, four should be okay.
Four is good.
It's gonna be really good.
Let's see how it runs.
Yeah, we can always adjust.
No worries.
Alright, start game.
Let's go, baby.
Kira, Kira, Kira, Kira.
I will never be Kira.
Stop being so cute.
What are you talking about?
Here we go.
Hello.
I have to give an item to Bobear.
Okay.
Good luck with that.
What am I doing?
NPCs.
Questioning.
It should be possible to identify Kira if you have all information of the events.
What does that mean?
In here?
No.
Wait.
What am I...
Oh, I'm monitoring.
I'm going around without my mic on this time, guys.
Someone must...
Oh.
We have help.
Vindicating evidence.
How did they get this?
So fast.
Wait, what are we doing?
Investigators can make contact with...
And prevent role reviews?
Oh.
Okay.
Interesting.
Vienna is an investigator.
We now...
Why does it always choose Vienna?
I think this game has a...
Oh, no!
This game has a bit of a...
Uh-oh.
Resolving, resolving.
Oh, my God.
I'm following Grimmie.
Following Grimmien.
We're going.
Someone might...
Wait, how do I do this?
Why is it not letting me do it?
There we go.
We're resolving?
Hello.
Who's not resolving?
There's three people in here.
I'm trying to.
I have an item with me.
I don't know what to do.
An item?
It's not letting me investigate.
I swear to you.
Please don't select me as Kira.
You will regret it.
I'm sorry.
I can't tell you more.
Interesting.
That's right.
Oh, my gosh.
There's so many NPCs I need to question.
So many people need questioning.
So many people that need questioning.
What are you doing up there, Grimmie?
Don't worry.
Here.
I have to monitor.
Found it on the ground.
I give back.
Here you go.
I'm monitoring you real quick, Vienna.
Wait, I don't know what I just did.
What did we just do?
Can I monitor you, please?
Okay, I'm going that way.
Oh, no.
There's not enough time left.
Oh, my gosh.
No!
My joint task!
Oh, my gosh.
Here?
Why is he so...
How did someone get murdered already?
Oh, my God!
He's so shit!
Guys, gotta be careful.
I put a safety on.
I literally just talking to Snuffy.
Holy shit!
That's so GG.
No, Snuffy!
But they were working with Minto.
It was a Nerf gun.
I don't know what happened.
There was like 10 seconds left when we had this collaboration.
And I couldn't do anything.
Okay, so is it not Snuffy that...
Oh, wait.
Snuffy is dead.
Probably not Snuffy, I'd say, yeah.
It's a new person because they're not doing anything.
Abby was stolen.
Blackaddy was stolen too.
Mine was stolen.
We were all investigating that body.
Investigated me and Blackaddy did not get stolen.
So I don't think it's Minto or Limu.
It's not me.
I...
We know it's not Vienna too, so...
Wait, why do we know it's not you guys?
I was...
Grimmy, who was investigating the body with us?
Because it announced that it wasn't Vienna.
Yeah, it said it was stolen.
My idea was stolen while I was investigating it.
I was by myself first and then four people surrounded me.
So it was... I couldn't even see who the four was because I was investigating that body first.
I know that I was in close contact with Grimmy a couple of times.
The people that I've been near are Bao and Grimmy, I think.
Wait, whose ID got stolen again?
My ID got stolen.
Mine.
Because I was in that body thing on the top left.
Oh, okay.
I was with Grimmy back during that.
And someone else.
So maybe Bao pretended to want a property.
But I did give you stuff back though.
And I was giving a lost package back.
It's not my ID though.
I've still lost that, so...
I don't think we have enough evidence.
Yeah, why did you give back her ID?
I don't think it's actually lost packages or not IDs.
It said deliver package and I was trying to go around to deliver the one package back.
And I had the ID to give back to you.
Toki, why are you investigator investigator?
Investigator investigator.
You can change your name tag.
You can change your name tag in the customization.
I'm here.
All of my lonesome.
I'm investigating.
No one's been here.
Going to the meeting room.
Where is that?
If he kills people who oppose him, even if they're innocent, then Kira is really just a murderer.
I don't think it's Grimmie, you guys.
I don't think it's Grimmie.
Grimmie was down here while everybody whose wallets got stolen were up in the left.
So I really don't think it's her.
Amelie is...
Oh, okay.
I don't think it's Amelie.
Because she... Why would he say something about Transceiver otherwise?
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
Oh my gosh, there's so many more!
There's so many more now!
WD.
Okay.
Oh, and I gotta monitor someone.
Oh my gosh.
Am I gonna be able to do all this?
Holy cow.
Maybe there's too many tasks now.
I rather... I just wanted like a variety of tasks.
But it's just talk to people and...
Someone supposedly handed off a black notebook during...
Wait, so there is a follower.
I think we have a follower this time.
Oh my gosh!
The car!
What the hell just happened?
Wait, did someone die?
Okay.
Three people...
Did someone die?
I'm going to go check.
Who died?
What?
Oh my god.
I'll post your names on the internet!
Oh my god!
The isekai truck!
She's in a better place now.
Those 3D models in this look so good.
Like Kira?
I know!
They look really good.
Kira looks so good.
Oh my god.
I was doing a joint thing with Amelie and she just collapsed next to me.
I was like, Amelie, what's going on?
She stopped talking and then she just passed out.
Oh my gosh.
Come on, do your tasks, everybody.
There we go.
We're doing our tasks right now.
It's really hard to win by doing tasks.
Level 41 is crazy.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Three.
Three of them.
That means three died, right?
Cause the last one was like...
Zero.
Yeah.
Uh oh.
Hmm.
Well, I was with Amelie doing a joint investigation and then she collapsed.
Right next to you.
I think there's also...
I think there's a follower this round too.
Because one of the little people that I investigated said that they saw someone passing off the notebook.
Like the little NPC.
Oh, wait.
Which side was it?
Which... Do you remember?
Maybe you can open the map with M.
Was it in the beginning or the middle?
It was when it was daytime.
It was the one by the... It said in the classroom that they passed it off.
I think it's... I think it's maybe Vau and Juniper.
It is...
I mean, I can't really say anything to defend myself, but it's not me.
Puts hands up.
I got an investigation.
Very convincing.
Yeah, in a very submissive way.
I get like really submissive.
I like lay on the ground, I roll over, I show my belly.
Okay, well, I'm gonna pee on the floor.
There's a giant puddle of pee underneath me.
I think that's our culprit.
And I hate being anything...
I hate being anything that involves me having to lie.
I pick investigator literally every time.
Let's go!
So...
I got a dying message from Snuffy, but I don't really understand it.
So I think that was a confession, right, Vau?
How is that a confession?
Right?
You can read people's notebooks by...
If you go into like the thing, it'll show you which ones they have marked off.
Oh god, there's ten seconds, never mind!
I don't know, I don't know!
It's Juniper!
It's not Juniper!
Wait, it's not Juniper.
How do we know?
Yo, I'm chill.
Let me do it.
Oh my gosh!
You're going downtown, Charlie Brown!
Yep, you're going into Slammer.
Why didn't you even do anything?
So, poor Claim, standard investigator.
Get back!
I can explain.
Got it.
Now you killed too many people.
The moment I gave...
I thought I was supposed to!
The moment I gave her the notebook, she killed everybody.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, it was you!
Is that not the point of the death note?
You did it so cool!
I just thought if I murked everyone, I'd win!
She went fucking wild!
She was like...
She was crazy with it, damn!
I could have sworn that was the point of the book called the death note!
Oh my gosh.
I could be my favorite character.
Me too!
Oh, is it time?
Oh my gosh, we're all this ugly ass.
What the hell is this version of Kira?
Why is there this version and this?
I'm investigator, investigator.
You're gonna be investigator, investigator.
Yeah!
I legitimately thought it was like only Kira's can be investigator.
I was like, wait a minute.
But I was like, oh my gosh, I changed it.
We have so many more new characters now, it's so exciting.
Oh yeah.
I don't remember this guy.
Misa is so ugly, I can't...
Dude, it's so crazy that you have to pay money to be cute in Moe.
I know!
That's not just me, but...
It's brilliant, honestly.
That's how they get you.
Yeah!
There's like the Nendoroids and then there's the little bootleg figures.
Nendos!
Oh my god.
Which way, western man?
I don't know what this says.
I'm also saying this because I dogged on Doki pretty hard for this, but it's only because I did the same thing.
But if you get Kira and one of those things happen, do not read out loud that it says to judge people.
Do not read out loud!
Investigators don't see the judging thing.
Nobody noticed, except for Snuffy, so I was like, you're out.
You're out of the game.
Same thing, and I was like, I said it out loud, and I was like, wait, that sounds like something that only...
But I forgot.
Snuffy literally told me, and I forgot.
And that's why I made Snuffy shoot herself.
That was so good.
But you, Kira, until you pass off the death note, and then the other person becomes Kira?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they become Kira.
You can make somebody else cute up.
So when I gave my notebook to Bao, she went fucking crazy.
She was like, I found it.
Bao was like frothing at the mouth, like, finally.
Wait, that's also interesting then, because that means that the collaboration things that happen with L aren't always the safe people.
No, no, no, you don't know the safe L, basically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, interesting.
Or putting two people together and seeing what happens.
Okay.
Yeah, you see, like, if they get together and the other person died.
Alright, are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Oh, no!
Every single time!
Stay safe out there.
Wait, okay.
Let's go talk to some... Oh, not that person.
Wait, person in here.
Juniper, can I monitor you respectfully?
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, oh.
Excuse me.
Wait.
What's happening?
Oh, wait.
How do I...
Oh, there we are.
Okay, I'm monitoring respectfully.
Thank you.
What?
Why?
Why are you talking to me?
I'm investigating this spot.
Wait.
We have to investigate.
What is this?
Oh my god, wait, this way?
Can someone help me in here?
Oh, I'm here.
Sorry, I forgot to press the...
The thingy.
There we go.
Thank you.
Yeah, this person's dead.
Sure looks dead to me.
I don't believe how dead they are, holy shit.
Nah, freaking dead.
Yay!
She did not... Did she see me...
Did she see me writing at the death note?
I don't think she saw.
Okay.
Who am I following?
Oh.
Amelie, I would like to follow you respectfully.
Oh, may I judge you respectfully?
Respectfully, may I judge you Amelie?
Oh.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
What's happening?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Jesus, oh my god.
Holy shit.
Eyes wide open.
No, she knew too much!
She looked up.
Who found her notebook?
I have her notebook, but she had nothing in it.
She was not doing her homework.
Literally, I was like, I looked in it and like, nothing.
I'll be honest, I don't do my homework.
Are you supposed to... Wait, it doesn't put in the names automatically?
You're supposed to put notes on who you think is like, most suspicious.
Oh.
Yeah, so you click on them.
Um, before Donofer died...
Before she died, she said...
Yeah, yeah, she told me in Vienna.
Though Vienna did steal my ID, so I don't know.
Yes, you did!
My ID was stolen!
I still have my ID.
No, I don't...
Wait.
No!
Wait, why do you think F is Kira?
Hey, question, can Kira followers help you with the incident resolution?
Yeah, they can help.
Okay, the only person that was close...
Everybody can help you, I think you can do that.
Oh...
Kira was an incident really close, and Mint ran away from it.
Instead of going to one that was closer.
Oh, no, I went to one!
I went to one!
Someone was talking through Transceiver near Hotel Teton during the day.
On the bottom portion of the map, someone was seen at night...
holding a notebook and opening it.
Does increasing the amount of tasks you can do in a day make the progress bar need more to fill up?
Because it actually feels like it's even longer now.
Longer, right?
Is it longer?
It feels like it.
I think so.
It feels like we're filling up less based on the levels we're getting.
Yeah, I think I actually made it longer now.
It's also really hard to get to everybody.
I don't know.
I think because you also lowered the day too, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, so Vienna, why do you think it's Snuffy?
Juniper said it was Snuffy.
And now she's dead.
Okay, Loki, I feel stupid about it.
What did she say?
She said it was Snuffy and she's dead now.
She said it was Snuffy because...
You know what?
Let's do it.
Let's take a shot.
I don't think it's Snuffy.
I have a confession to make.
Yeah, that seems like a confession right there.
I have a confession.
No, no, no.
I can't hear anybody.
I tried to text her.
I was texting her.
Again?
Oh, I remember.
I'm not going to say anything more than that.
You can judge based on that.
But I literally can't figure it out.
I can't figure out anything.
She was pecking an NPC.
And the NPC said no one had visited.
But Snuffy was there.
I can't hear anybody.
Like anybody at all this time.
It's just getting worse every game.
I hear less and less people.
She literally can't hear.
I'm not cute, by the way, though.
I'm not cute.
Are you bad?
Are you a little bad?
Are you...
A little bad?
Oh, nothing.
Oh my gosh!
It is a person!
Oh God.
Guys, this is hard.
I think they just killed somebody.
I think.
Wait.
What the?
Oh wait.
Oh my...
Hello, Doki.
Where's my person?
Oh my God.
I said the judge.
Oh my gosh.
Do we not do it here?
Guys,
this is scary.
I don't like actually being this.
Oh my God.
Oh.
I don't like it.
What the hell is this?
What's happening?
What the hell is that?
Oh my gosh, I see like...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Cannot judge until the next day.
Oh, I can do this though.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Can I do like command cards or anything though?
Hello?
Why aren't you talking to me?
You sus?
Hello?
Wait, Snuffy is...
Snuffy is arrested.
Hello?
I can't hear anybody.
I can't hear you.
Stay away from me.
I can't hear...
Hello?
Oh, who is it?
I got mugged.
This is so funny.
This is so slow motion.
I love just being deaf and like just harassing the person I'm trying to.
Oh my God.
So bad.
Lime and Bao.
Okay, I'm just wondering this time for sure.
You guys can hear me now, right?
Yeah.
So, new update on this.
I can't hear anybody, but I can actually hear all the people who are dead.
But they can't hear me.
Wait, Doki, were you talking to me?
Yeah, yeah.
I think the mic bugged out.
I think it bugged.
I couldn't hear you.
Oh my God.
I found Limu's dead body and her notebook had mint only circled.
I can perform a seance with the dead.
Guys, just listen to me.
What did the dead say, Snuffy?
What did he tell you?
Guys, who killed you?
Let me know.
What is she saying?
Hello?
You couldn't say.
I couldn't hear you.
Hello?
What is that?
By the words, he asked her why she was like, it's Snuffy in the end.
I like how Snuffy is legend, legend.
FBI, FBI.
What are these titles?
Open up, FBI, FBI.
That's me.
I found a try to... Sorry, Mint, but in the beginning, I was next to you and my ID card was stolen.
And then now, Lime had your name circled.
So it makes me think it's you.
I was doing... I was investigating you.
I had a mission.
It was just to investigate you.
That's suspicious.
Here's the thing.
When I talked to an NPC like last round who was like, oh yeah, well in this area, someone was seen at night opening a book.
It had just turned to night time like 20 seconds before and only Mint was in that area.
Well, it could have been you too.
What do you mean by that?
You wouldn't have talked to that guy if it was me.
You could be making that up.
I know.
I talked to the people too and they say things.
She's stumbling.
She's panicking.
Kira would never panic.
Long live Kira!
I actually can't tell who's dead and who's alive.
So if I'm responding to people you can't even hear, I'm so sorry.
I'm talking to my imaginary friend.
Yeah, communicate with the dead.
What do they have to say about Mint?
I'm innocent!
You said long live Kira.
I mean, I'm a follower.
I should have given the notebook to you Snuffy, goddammit.
I'm inexperienced, don't blame me!
I believe the person's name, whose shirt is literally saying Kira.
It's a prop, it's for a movie, we're making a live action Death Note.
Oh my god, you're making Death Note 2 on Netflix?
Yeah.
Oh my god, I'm locked up forever.
You're looking a little goofy.
Good job.
There's always the one you least suspect.
I got kinda far-ish.
I'm just glad I got to live and harass you guys.
Why Moo, why did you have to play the game and circle my name?
Oh my god.
Her final message.
Mint.
I wonder what a circle around Mint's name could mean.
I don't know.
I'm sorry Mint.
Live Moo was actually playing the game.
I need to okay all of you.
Circle people's names?
Yeah, that's what the notebook is for.
That's what it's for.
To be fair, I've been Kira like 99% of the time.
Wait a minute.
Oh, well this is awkward.
I'm gonna change my role preference.
Too many chefs.
Oh, I can be a chef too.
Oh wait, I like how we're all getting the same stuff at the same time.
So everyone ends up wearing the same shit.
Not me, I'm an individual.
I picked a bow instead.
I picked those.
Trying to make myself look atrocious.
Look at my cute little bow.
I'm adorable.
I took a shower.
I like how Snuffy is the only one that took the shower cap.
I took the shower.
We're buddies.
But I paid for the afro, so I have to use it.
Alright, alright.
You know when Gaia online, when people were fangirling over L?
This is how they drew him.
Just with a cute little bow and pretty glasses.
So cute!
Oh my god, he even had the roundest headroom.
You're so cute.
So cute!
Baby girl L.
Baby girl.
Ugly ass stupid bull G.I.
An L, a Q, a near, a mellow, or a matte fan?
Alright, I'm upping my mellow fan.
Which one?
What was your favorite fella?
Mosquito.
Mosquito?
You're not here?
Am I the only one hearing the buzz?
Oh no.
Alright, I made it so that tasks go by faster now.
Alright, let's see if it does work though.
It definitely won't for me.
Good luck everybody.
Sorry guys, this is my dinner.
And also my breakfast, so I'm really hungry.
Oh god.
Grimmy?
What were you saying no about?
What was that about?
Oh mask?
I'm blowing air, literally.
I'm just spreading all my germs in all directions.
Okay.
I just wanna keep eating my sandwich, I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, I'm supposed to keep distance?
Grimmy's pretty sus, I'm gonna say.
Grimmy's pretty sus.
Two people.
Two people came by today.
Two of them.
Oh shoot, it's already night.
Oh, what's happening?
Death note test.
In here?
I'm resolving.
It says only two people are resolving.
More resolving.
Four of us.
Okay, slime on Juniper.
Yeah, I did.
Is it in here?
No.
Wait, can I get this person though?
Oh, I have to talk to this person.
Five people came by today.
Oh no, it's the other direction.
Spread your germs.
Who am I investigating?
Limel!
Limel, can I follow you respectfully?
Okay, thank you.
Oh wait, the person I'm investigating is in here.
Someone was talking on the transceiver during the day.
The park.
What's the transceiver?
How do you use the transceiver?
Oh yeah, you guys did the same thing.
In the park, during the day?
Where's the park?
Park is this way.
I completed all my tasks.
Who's that over there?
They look suspicious.
Oh my god!
Everybody takes out Limel first because she's so powerful.
Dude, this happens to her every game.
If she's not the first to be a killer, she's the first to die.
When it was my turn, I actively avoided killing her so she could keep playing the game.
There's other choices.
There was gun, chandelier, all that shit, but they picked the truck.
That's their signature.
That's just their signature.
Limel, can I still hear you?
I don't think I can.
Oh, I can.
What is she saying?
What is Limel saying?
It's none of your business.
Only I get to talk to her.
I think it's Doki.
How did you know that they could have picked anything?
Because I was Kira before.
Yeah, but you didn't kill anyone.
We didn't kill anyone as Kira.
You didn't kill anyone before as Kira.
I think Doki stole it.
Doki got really close to me and then did nothing about it and just turned around and didn't go anywhere.
And she just wanted to get really close to me.
What do you mean?
I was doing the fucking best thing.
I have a really good sense of smell that I have lost my sense of smell.
So I can smell the fuss on you.
But you know what they say, when you lose one of your senses...
You said Doki, when you were the killer last time, you immediately gave it to someone else.
That is true.
You didn't kill anyone before.
Two people, Snuffy and someone else, and then I gave the book to somebody else.
All they call me is...
You're going to be so surprised when it's not me.
She's starting to lag, so she's definitely what Kira would do.
Do it.
Arrest me.
Okay, it has to be her, right?
Why is she cutting out?
Go to jail.
Wait, why is Grimmie voting for Amelie?
Undo, undo, undo.
Wait, why is it Amelie?
She's kind of a freak.
Let's put Amelie in the jail cell instead.
Someone handcuffed me.
Someone handcuffed me to somebody.
And then my ID was gone.
And now she's going, it has to be Doki, it has to be Doki.
I'm sure it's Amelie.
Amelie was right next to where Laimu died, actually.
I was right, I almost got hit by the car.
It missed me by a millimeter.
What was that?
Did we have to select someone?
I think someone applied a little funny thing when you vote someone else.
Wait, who am I going to vote next to, Doki?
What if I'm into that snuffy?
That's right.
Oh no.
New world investigator.
Oh no!
It's...
Ok, now you can start barking for me.
Let me poke you around all game.
It's Amelie, it's Amelie, it's Amelie.
I think it's Amelie too.
I think it's also Amelie.
Wait, we gotta tell L then.
Hey!
Oh my God.
No, Vienna, no!
Vienna, don't let her!
Don't let her, Vienna!
Oh my God.
I must investigate you.
I think it is Amelie.
What the hell is this?
You just have Doki.
Oh my God.
Hey, stay away from me!
It's Amelie, it's Amelie.
We gotta get her.
5 people resolving?
Ok.
That's a lot of resolvers.
Oh gosh, all of us are in trouble.
It's Amelie!
You guys have to believe me!
I got Limu's book!
Because all she did was...
Limu was only in contact with Bao and Amelie.
And Amelie is so sus.
Wait, how do I get around here?
I wish there was a back door, man.
There is a little red word next to the bear name now.
Drive by investigation?
Thank you.
I
don't think it's Bao.
Doki, you are like a fucking dog.
Oh my God.
What happened?
What?
Who?
You knew!
We were too late!
Sorry Grimmy, I tried to spread your gospel.
Ok,
but I was right about Doki.
I was right about Doki.
Wait a second, I gave away my IDs before.
She passed off the book, didn't she?
I was just giving her all the IDs.
But I had no IDs so I could live.
This is actually more fun when you like kind of get the idea of the game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we play another one?
I'm gonna try.
I don't know.
I tried doing that before and it didn't work.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
No, because I can still hear everybody.
Like right now I can hear everybody.
It's literally only when the game plays.
I didn't see a setting that's like...
That's so weird.
Everybody.
And like I can hear Limes but she can't hear me and she's also dead and I'm not.
That's weird.
That's so weird.
Like day one bug maybe.
Maybe.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, there's...
As long as Snuffy can still hear me, I'm gonna like annoy the shit out of her every time I die, I guess.
She's like the seance.
Lime, what is Lime saying?
Snuffy, tell us her final words.
What is it?
Are we all here?
We're missing one person.
I think...
Didn't Snuffy leave to try and rejoin?
Oh, Snuffy.
Oh yeah, he said Snuffy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Snuffy's trying to fix it.
We're slowly understanding the game now.
Yeah.
We have different maps in the future.
Yeah, and like different tasks to do rather than just talk to people and stalk people.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
To be fair, this game came out so fucking fast so I feel like they were like, gotta drop it now.
For what reason?
I don't understand.
It needs a little bit of like cleaning up.
Yeah.
I like the ideas of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's another alternative.
Yeah, that's fun.
The Among Us, there's no alternative.
It makes you think and like, suspect people in different ways because of the notebooks and stuff.
It's fun.
Yeah, you gotta like, look everywhere.
I'm like, why are you so close to me?
Yeah.
Why are you so close to me?
I don't like every little thing that gets stuck.
Yeah, yeah.
Back up!
I also like the music.
I think the music is good.
Yeah, she looks like...
We're supposed to practice COVID protocols here.
Why are you guys all so close?
Mask up, mask up, mask up, mask up.
Six feet, mask up, mask up.
Guys, guys, guys.
Only one person here is wearing a mask, right?
Two people are wearing masks.
I'm spreading my germs in all directions.
I'm literally blowing out into the world.
I'm kind of sneezing right now.
I wonder who gave it to me.
Alright, Snuffy, can you hear us?
Yes.
I'm beyond brave.
But I'm starting the game.
We'll have to see in the game.
If someone's next to Snuffy, confirm.
Okay, hoping for you.
We hope.
Of course.
I wanna be L now.
I wanna at least be L.
I wanna be L.
I want to be L.
When will I be L?
Snuffy?
Who's next to me?
Hello, Giga?
Wait, why can't I move?
Oh, there we go.
I'm good.
Snuffy?
I can hear you.
Okay, good.
And I'm investigating in this little parking lot.
I'm gonna go question some NPCs.
This looks like an Oreo, doesn't it?
I have some Oreos in my pantry.
I'm gonna eat an Oreo after this.
Two people.
Oh, there they were.
Who was that?
Amelie and Snuffy?
Hello, Amelie?
Hi.
Oreo-thins?
I've never had an Oreo-thin.
Oh, oh my goodness.
I'm literally monitoring nothing.
Doing nothing.
I'm not supposed to, I'm not supposed to...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
How do we... Where's the dead body?
Oh my God, there's so many people in here.
Ah, they're a freak then.
Whoever they are.
Uh oh, this way maybe?
Yes, let's go, Snuffy.
I trust you.
Okay, we're here to help.
Oh, we failed.
Oh gosh.
Oh, so sad.
Okay.
Yeah.
Where'd you guys go?
Oh my God, oh my God, I'm trying to... Oh my God, I think I got stolen.
I got stolen from, maybe.
No, if it says it just means you've been in close enough proximity to get it stolen.
If that makes sense.
Yeah, but it could have been stolen by you.
Oh wait, Laimo, I have an item for you.
Laimo?
What do I do?
Oh, what do I do with this?
Okay.
I actually don't really know.
Oh, investigator Amelie.
Save, Amelie's safe.
No!
What?
Someone in my chat literally just said Amelie's sus.
No.
Well, Amelie just gets a pass now.
It just says she was an investigator.
I trust that.
Wow.
Alright.
Nothing happened.
Nobody's dead.
That's weird that nobody did anything.
Yeah, that's a little suspicious.
They don't want us to know just yet.
Not me.
That was me.
They're playing the long game.
I'm someone not very good at Aira.
Might be it.
Whoa, and who do you...
That's crazy.
You stole my ID, though.
What the fuck?
I don't even have my own ID.
I think it's Val.
Wait, no one's ID was stolen?
Mine was.
Oh, okay, just kidding.
It is literally not me.
I have been doing all my investigations and talking to every single NPC.
I went to every single investigation when a body died except the last one because I got lost.
The only people that I don't suspect right now is Giga, Doki, and Amelie.
And Minto.
The only people who didn't come close enough to me to steal my identity but the rest of you.
Snuffy, Snuffy, I wasn't right next to it.
Minto's so suspicious of me.
I think it's Doki because I was next to Doki and my card got stolen, I think.
We also failed.
I said my card got stolen.
I was like, holy shit, how did she do that?
Did you guys see anybody whacking off?
You were what?
By the body?
You were whacking off?
Whacking off by the body?
No, you were next to it.
You guys, she was just sitting on the cameras.
I was talking about the camera case.
Why did we put webcams in the toilet?
Fira was not jorking his penis.
How would you know that, investigator?
How do you know that?
I wasn't watching.
Right, right.
We're getting a little off topic here.
I vote out.
That there's something up with Limu.
Limu's been very quiet.
Limu has been very quiet.
We've had no drunk drivers today.
Limu hasn't been over yet.
What the fuck?
Limu is a liar.
It has to be her.
Let me see your licenses, everyone.
Wait, how do I...
License.
Alright, Limu.
It's a little suspicious that you're still alive.
A little weird.
We'll keep that in mind.
Do you think it's a little sus how accusatory some people are being?
Yeah, I think so.
I think it could be a little sussy.
Yeah, it's a lot.
Just a thought.
Much to think about.
I'm gonna go monitor Riena.
Riena, please, I'm monitoring you.
Thank you, I'm sorry.
I'm monitoring you.
OK, I have a little person.
Perhaps Doki?
God, it really is on my side.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot.
No one's been here.
OK, I'm here though.
I lived!
What do you mean you lived?
We got hit by a car, but we're OK.
Were you like shoved into here?
Oh, that's happened to me.
It happened to me in the tutorial, yeah.
OK, three people resolving.
Where's everybody else?
Oh, that means one of us is not resolving.
I was resolving.
Otherwise I would have not known that number.
We're resolving?
So this bus didn't actually kill anyone?
No, it just killed Kira.
It prevents the new god from... like the new world order.
Wait, who just said I'm Kira?
It was you!
It was you, Doki, was it not?
No, it wasn't.
What the fuck?
I was investigating.
No, I think it was you who said I'm Kira.
No, I would never.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, typical Kira.
Oh, wait, I'm going in here.
Hey, stop stealing my stuff.
Oh, hello?
Hey, hey!
Who could be Kira?
Wait.
Cafe.
Wait, where is that?
Oh my gosh, I still have more.
Oh my gosh, and who?
I'm monitoring Grimmy.
Who was that?
Who was what?
Circle Doki's name.
Oh, dang it.
Set up surveillance.
I'm grabbing it.
Someone... Hey!
Stay away.
Oh, I need to go down here?
Oh my gosh.
That in here?
Okay, here we go.
I did it.
I did my part.
Okay, I need to do my other tasks.
Never mind, we have 10 seconds.
This is... The tasks are...
Tricky to do sometimes.
Oh, there's Grimmy!
Who was near me?
Juniper was near me?
No.
Don't do that.
We can be civil.
I like how that's a huge threat.
I'm gonna post your name on the internet.
Oh my God!
Two.
We know Amelie was proven innocent.
Vienna, you know what to do.
Okay, okay.
So, what does that mean?
Giga and Mint were walking together and Mint said I have to investigate you.
But Mint didn't actually stand close enough to me to investigate me.
But Giga did and said she also had to investigate me.
What?
What are the chances they both had to investigate me and were together?
And Mint didn't complete her investigation.
What?
I did complete my investigation.
I was close enough.
What do you mean I wasn't close enough?
I did my investigation.
Time the thing off for me.
Who was it?
Wait, who was it though?
Her internet might have gone out again.
That was a really good game so far though.
I was eating that shit up.
That was drama.
That was some drama.
Oh my God.
So who was the killer?
Who was it?
It was me and Limo.
Giga, I trusted you!
That's the real strategy of Limo.
Limo, did it freak you the fuck out when I instantly voted for you?
I went to tell Doki that I thought it was Giga and she got hit by the car in front of me.
She was too sus of me at one point.
Dude, I just got hella good at this conversation.
I knew it couldn't have been anyone else in that room where we were looking at the body, but Limo was also there.
I feel so bad.
I saw Grimmy in an alleyway and was instantly like, Grimmy must be it.
Hey bro, welcome back!
Welcome back!
Yay!
What happened?
Who was Kira?
It was me and Limo.
Okay, I didn't know you.
I know, I just didn't.
Giga, we were buddies.
Giga was like, rising me up.
She was like, do you think everybody is being a little too accusatory?
And I was like, yeah, I think so, yeah.
I was marinating so hard, dude.
I was like, yeah, I trust you.
I was just like, oh my god.
First mistake.
Trust nobody, not even yourself.
If Limo lives past first round, we know.
It's true.
Alright, let's go.
I want to be L.
Why can't I be L?
Take this potato chip and I'll eat it.
Oh.
Sus, that's really strange of you.
Actually, Bao, can you come here?
I got to investigate you real quick.
Thank you.
Take a note.
No, maybe.
I don't know.
I'm a part time thief.
You know?
Nobody's been here.
Excuse me.
Oh, mine's in here.
Just kidding.
Five people, holy moly.
I'm chilling here.
Grimmy, what are you doing?
You want to sit on the bench here?
It's a pleasant day, right?
Oh, Juniper, I got to investigate you.
Thank you.
You were really willing about that.
Were you taking my ID when I did that?
I just got a job to do, you know?
And you do too if you're a killer.
I'll remember that.
I'm going to turn the volume up a little bit more.
Please cooperate.
No one's been here.
Wait, in here?
OK, Juniper is safe.
Nevermind.
What about you, Amelie?
Are you taking my... Are you going to take it?
Are you going to take my thing?
OK.
Transceiver.
Hey!
Hello.
Yeah, me too.
Do you need... Do you need to monitor me?
No, I'm just... I'm just following.
I wish you could mark who you think it's not.
That would be awesome.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, just keep on checking.
Just put all of them suspicious and then you just start marking people who you think it's not.
I did all my tasks.
Holy cow.
Oh my god, we did so much.
Jesus.
Nice.
Kira...
Kira is a little confused.
Sleepy Kira.
It's OK, Kira.
He's just going to kill when we least expect it.
Right away, I think we can rule out Doki and Snuffy.
Wait, why?
People would already be dead if I was Kira.
If I was Kira, I would have killed people.
Belle, why did you say you were going to take a chip and eat it?
Because I was reciting the lines from the anime.
Yeah, but you could have recited an innocent person's line.
Yeah, that's Kira's line.
That's a Kira line.
Yes, because it's a funny bit I do at the beginning of every round.
You know what?
I believe...
I was with you in the beginning of one of the rounds and you didn't say it.
You didn't say it when I was with you last time.
Because you were busy saying something sus too!
I would never.
You literally said, I can't wait to put everyone's names in this book.
Yeah, in my journal.
My investigation notepad.
Oh my god.
This is a lot of accusations for literally nothing happening.
I'm just going to say that.
Finally, some reasoning.
Yeah, always sus if people are pointing out you the most immediately.
You took me at the start of the round, Snuffy, and my ID's gone.
I mean, I think my ID's gone too.
Has there been a round where somebody actually has never had their ID taken?
Wait, but if your ID's gone, who do you think took it?
Well, I had to give Juniper a present, but then she was also proven to be the investigator.
So I'm not really sure...
I think I was around, but you're not accusing me.
If I was right next to you too.
And Juniper's ID...
I feel like I can't go off of IDs, because I'm usually touching like 8 people.
Whoever is checked on your investigation pad as like an exclamation point is somebody you were that close to.
And it's usually like 5 out of 8 people.
I only have 8 people.
But I'm watching you.
Who hasn't been touched this round?
I said my ID and I was next to Juniper.
And Juniper still has her ID, so we're fine.
But Juniper's good at this.
Okay, Bao.
I don't think it's you, after all.
Sorry for saying that.
That's okay.
I get it.
Not everyone understands my underground humor.
Yeah.
I think it's her.
Actually, I realized I marked that, but I didn't actually get close enough for her to steal it.
Death note test.
Oh no!
I'm going this way.
I'm going around.
Who are you waiting for, Giga?
Who are you waiting for?
Oh shoot.
Alright.
Why aren't you resolving anything, huh?
Oh, okay.
I'm literally resolving right now.
I literally just got here.
Giga's here.
Giga?
No, it's just me.
No, there's only two people resolving.
Giga, why aren't you resolving?
Giga, it's you!
Giga, press it!
I was here before you!
No, you weren't.
I didn't see it.
Alright, now I know if my ID is gone, now I know.
It's Giga, it's Giga, it's Giga.
Yeah, I think it's Giga.
Hello?
Where's the classroom?
Oh my God.
A player who could be curi... Oh, classroom is down here.
Body was found at the restroom.
What the...
Body?
Body.
What's the restroom?
Wait.
Huh?
Where's the restroom?
I'm trying my best and...
Huh?
I'm gonna do my tasks.
Help where?
It's not on here.
Top left?
Oh my God.
What happened?
Wait, what happened?
Oh shoot, who died?
That's so true.
She makes a fair point.
Wait.
You think it's Doki?
I'm not gonna make the last person.
Oh, maybe I will.
Oh, so close.
There it is.
It's over, dude.
It's over.
The chef hat.
Oh my God.
Another heart attack.
Oh, Juniper died too.
She was just innocent.
It's too good to be true.
I'm the class clown.
You should protect the people who get labeled as such.
They're obviously gonna be targeted.
I was supposed to monitor Amelie.
Don't even say it, bro.
You're so dumb, dude.
Amelie's trying to set me up and make it look like I killed them.
If you're Kira, you would literally be able to kill anyone from anywhere.
Why would I kill both of them next to me and then just stand there?
Doki, I think it's you.
Because you could be the follower.
You could be a follower.
You could be a sheep.
Her last message was that also my ID has been stolen.
Mine too.
I wrote down who was close to me.
Wait, what if she killed a past mom?
I was only close to Giga.
Val, Mint, and Giga were close to me.
My ID got stolen and the only one I went close enough to this round was Giga.
Yeah, me too.
Because I gave her a thing.
It's Giga.
Oh, she gave me a present.
She gave me a gift.
I only got to defend myself.
I gave you a gift, but my ID got stolen and nobody else has been close enough to me.
Yeah.
None of you have died, though.
You think it's Giga, Val?
I think Snuffy's the follower, baby.
Sorry, Snuffy.
On what basis?
I don't know anymore.
Giga, what do you have to say for yourself?
Giga might not actually be...
Giga might not actually be Kira because I also saw a witness say that an ID got, like, handed off.
But I think Giga's involved either way.
But also, Giga didn't help us with the body.
Oh my god.
And I stepped back.
That's true.
Because every time we stepped...
Giga was on us while we were doing the body.
Yeah.
I didn't click on it because every time we stack up, like, everyone's ID gets stolen, so I've been stepping back.
Yeah, but you...
I've been leaving, like, one or two to do it.
You stole the ID.
Yeah, but my ID's gone.
That was the only time I was super close to people.
That's pretty suspect.
That's the only time?
Yeah, that's the only time I'm really scared of physical touch.
It could be Doki, but since we also have Lime's arseholes against Giga...
I mean, I think it's enough votes already.
I don't think you need to overcook.
With two people dead, we should vote anyway.
True.
Yeah.
What does it mean to, like, does it matter who we pick to confiscate items?
Because if you pick the bad person, they can get the bad.
Yeah, if you pick a Kira follower, they can get it back, basically.
Wait, why did you pick Kira Bow and went on a walk with me, Giga?
What if Bow is a follower?
I'm not!
My name is Bow!
I just dropped it.
Very interesting.
We cooked!
Oh, we did it.
I actually wasn't Kira originally.
I was the follower, and then, like, right before the round ended, it got passed to me, and I was like...
Unlucky.
I literally killed somebody right before Laimu saw me, and so I thought, like, Doki saw me so easily one time, so I thought Laimu would have just instantly seen me and been like, oh shit, I just saw her kill somebody, so I was like, uh, you can take this.
Laimu, how did you?
Giga, you are so suspicious.
I'm sorry, but how did you block nothing?
Up to no good.
How did you know?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it wasn't you, Bow.
I'm so sorry.
One billion IQ.
I can't believe it wasn't her.
I get it.
I was like, it's Bow, and then I went to go check the tiers, and I was like, oh, Bow is L, oh no.
I literally mentioned my lead investigator too.
You were L?
What the...
Oh my god.
That was LG for me.
I gotta run.
That's LG.
Okay.
That was fun.
Yeah, that was fun.
I'm sorry, Giga.
That was so fun.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you all for coming.
This was so much fun.
Thanks for inviting.
Bye, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye-bye.
I like that this game has in-voice chat.
It helps a lot.
Yeah.
That way, I can also do things where I can just make the game all about me.
And it's Minecraft.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm not gonna do that again.
You were so good.
Thank you, guys.
Yeah, you were so good.
Oh, thank you.
I wanna get L sometime.
That was really fun.
Me too.
I was thinking that.
Yeah, I wanna get L too.
I wanna know what that was like.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, thank you, guys.
Yeah, GG.
GG.
Bye-bye.
Sorry about the tech issues.
Alright, bye.
Bye.
Room now.
Oh, there it goes.
Oh, it's my room now.
That was so silly.
What?
I think if they add a few more things to it, like a few more maps and tasks and things like that, I think it could be pretty solid.
I like the different way that you have to investigate people.
And the way you kill people is through getting their IDs and then having to do it sneakily through the notebook.
It's kind of interesting because usually with games like Among Us or Duck... wait, Goose Goose Duck, you know the killer if they're close by.
You'd be like, oh, I saw them running by, but you wouldn't know because they could kill them from anywhere.
So it's kind of... it's a fun way to change that aspect of the game.
Yeah, the death note mechanics.
Yeah, I hope they expand on it, though.
That'd be fun if they do.
Hopefully.
Yeah, I like it.
Killing from anywhere adds a cool twist.
I agree, I agree.
Hold on.
We're just saying, like, thanks for this fun game.
Because sometimes I know people don't like... Some people don't like these kinds of deduction games because sometimes they end up becoming like...
Like, you feel actually gas, you know, like you're getting gas lit or something and you're just like, oh, I don't want to lie.
I'm bad at lying.
But I think we're all very goofy.
So...
David, welcome to Mambo Ship Dark.
Gonzayo, thanks for six months.
And Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
I'm gonna...
Yeah, hopefully we get more maps.
I think that would help a lot.
Different locations and things.
Reminds me of a death note mod for Lethal Company.
What?
That exists?
I've been asking... I was telling Limu I really want to play Lethal Company.
Like, I never got to play Lethal Company, really, when the big boom happened.
So I'm, like, always still itching to play those kinds of games.
They're so fun for me.
Like, I think I could play, like, a whole week of Lethal Company.
You know?
I was completely lost at first, but the game looks fun after you figure it out.
How it works.
Thanks for the fun collab.
Yeah!
Yeah, no, I think we all were lost, right?
I think we all were pretty lost.
I'm going to switch over.
I want to chat.
Oh, where's my chat?
Where'd you guys go?
I want to talk for a bit before I head out.
Oh, there you are.
Give me some music.
There's a song, a piano man.
There we go.
Invisible.
Loading...
So late.
Thank you!
For a whole month?
Thanks!
It looks fun.
I have friends to play.
Nan, you can play online.
I think there was, like, open lobbies, too, so...
There were open lobbies, too, if you want to play.
Or, I'm sure you could get people in the Minto Discord together if anybody wanted to play.
How's my migraine?
I'm good!
Thanks for asking.
Yeah, I feel so much better.
I feel so good.
I got lots done today.
I was cleaning lots, and I was practicing a lot of the dance for the Phantom Thief concert.
So, I'm feeling good, I'm feeling good.
There's a Discord?
Yeah, I'm sure if you ever ask some Wisps, they could give you a Discord with the link.
Thanks for the stream, Minto!
So I can finally chat on PC again.
Yippee!
YouTube's so silly.
So silly.
Yeah, I had lots of fun with this.
I always like these kinds of games.
This one, I think, like I said, if I had a little bit more...
I think probably my favorite of all of them is Goose Goose Duck.
I think it's the most variety, and the most maps, and in-game features.
It's the ghostest with the mostest.
I think so.
You've seen me play that game the most.
Oh, I've never streamed that game before.
Are you seeing ghosts?
Yeah, I've never streamed that game.
Mint Discord is unofficial, right?
Yeah, it's unofficial.
I don't have an official Discord.
I don't plan on ever having an official Discord, but...
I don't know.
I used to have one a long, long time ago.
It's been a minute since I've done Akiba Tour.
A little bit has changed.
I wonder if the Google Maps has updated from some of the new buildings.
Like, there's a whole new Appa Hotel.
It's crazy.
Now there's like four Appa Hotels in Akiba.
I'm like, can you not build that?
Can you build something else instead?
I get it though.
A lot of the buildings I feel in Akiba recently have been needing to be torn down.
I think that's kind of the case with the Mr. Donuts.
I think the building is really old.
I think a lot of buildings in Akiba are really old and needing to be updated.
Imagine a Metal Gear style game where everyone is guards trying to figure out who's snaking right in.
That sounds like the most fun game ever.
That would be the...
Who knows how to program?
Joji!
Joji, I'm ready to throw money at you again.
Let's go.
I think Konami wouldn't like that.
It's Plissken.
Snake Plissken.
I wouldn't be making any money off of it.
I don't think Konami is like Nintendo where even if you make a fan property, they shut you down.
Right?
Probably.
Maybe.
Konami, please.
You mean Escape from New York, Snake Plissken?
Yeah.
Oh wait, but then...
It's just a fan game.
Snake Among Us fan game.
Wait, has Konami actually shut down multiple projects before?
I don't keep up with stuff like that usually.
They made official Castlevania DLC for Vampire Survivors, so you never know.
Yeah, exactly.
Well, Vampire Survivors like blew up.
So, we just have to make...
We just have to make...
Oh, wait, P.T.?
P.T.
was not a fan game, you guys.
P.T.?
I meant fan games.
P.T.
was them.
Oh, there was a fan remake.
There was a P.T.
fan remake that was shut down.
I see.
Well, I'll just make it not Metal Gear, and then maybe one day we can get the Metal Gear collaboration.
Nobody will play it though, because Among Us boom is gone.
So sad.
Nobody wants to play Among Us games anymore.
Among Us boom is gone.
You guys hear that clicking?
What is that noise?
Is that my computer?
Hold on.
What is that?
That's my computer.
I think the pump failing?
I think so, actually.
I've been having like a strange rattling recently.
That's either the fan or my cool...
I think it's my fan.
I've been having issues with...
This is the loudest it's rattled before though.
Yeah, you hear it?
I hate these stupid Corsair fans.
Oh my gosh, Corsair, I used to believe in you and now I'm such an auntie.
There goes my ever sponsorship.
These fans are so garbage.
I hate them so much.
Because they're like RGB fans, but their lights are totally off color.
It's so bad.
I'm scared.
Is my PC gonna be okay?
I'll check it after stream.
My Corsair LED fan needs to be replaced because of a busted LED.
Corsair fans are terrible.
I think the rattling, what was rattling in it before just became more loose.
I think.
That's what has happened.
You are stupid.
Stupid.
Aw man.
Wait, when am I streaming tomorrow?
Oh shoot, we're doing...
Oh no, we're doing Minecraft.
Oh gosh, computer, you have to hold out.
We're doing Minecraft.
Oh god.
You have to hold out.
I'm gonna be streaming for like probably 12 hours tomorrow.
Oh no, more doki.
I upgraded my computer with dual monitors just to watch you while playing games.
That's cool!
Hot dog.
Breaking news, Minto hates her fans.
Stop!
No!
Oh, it's such an annoying sound.
I'm sorry guys, I'm sorry.
It's so annoying for me.
I can't believe I can hear it through my headphones.
This is fun.
Oh wait, I forgot to put my menu back up.
Hold on.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, Minto 3.0 debut!
I can also hear it through my headphones, I'm sorry.
ViviCorn, thanks for the gifted!
Hold on, let me hit it.
Oh!
That worked!
If I press down on the top of my... If I press down on the top of my tower...
It stops for just a little bit.
Oh, there it goes.
If I like press... That's why I think I know it's the fan, because my fans are up top.
When I press down on it, it stops rattling.
And it's back.
There it goes.
Fan problem.
Might be a loose screw.
Hey, what are you saying about me?
You're saying I have a screw loose?
Well you're right!
Stop it!
It doesn't listen to me.
Okay, I was gonna talk for longer.
Ow, I just bit my...
I was gonna talk for longer, but now I feel like I have to look at my fan.
Oh gosh.
Didn't cause issues for a long time.
That's good.
Rattling fan is often just the fan sagging.
Can sometimes push them back on their spindle.
If you want nice RGB fans, look at Lee and Lee Uni fans.
Are they in white though?
Sorry.
I have an all white PC.
Are the Lee and Lee ones in white?
I used to have a Lee and Lee case.
I like Lee and Lee stuff.
They make them in white?
Yippee!
Japan takeover.
No!
Oh my gosh, it's gonna drive me insane.
I'm sorry guys.
John Yakuza, welcome to my workshop.
Thank you!
Minto PC case win?
I'm not popular enough.
I think I'm not popular enough for me to get a PC case.
I was thinking today, I would like to get to maybe 300k by the end of the year.
I don't know if it's possible.
I was thinking of ways.
Usually I don't care so much about my subscriber stuff.
But I was like, what can I...
What can I try and do...
To...
I don't know.
I was just like, what can I do?
You know.
You're going fast?
I think I'm going at my own Minto pace.
I usually don't care, like I said, about my subscriber count.
The only times when I care is when I want to collaborate with something.
When I'm just like, I want to collaborate with this creator or this company or something.
If I had more subscribers, maybe they would look at me.
I don't think I'm doing poorly or anything.
I'm not upset about it.
It's only then when I'm like...
I'm not popular enough.
But...
You know, it's okay.
I'm very comfortable where I am, you know.
Thanks for the 20 gift, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
For algorithm reasons?
It's less algorithm reasons and more like...
Sometimes if I want to work with a company or something...
They won't take me seriously because they might think that my numbers are too low.
You know what I mean?
Stuff like that.
Not like a...
It's like the perception to them.
Like, oh, you don't have...
You don't have...
1 million subscribers?
You're not popular.
Kind of deal.
So...
Yeah, it's really just that.
But, you know.
Not that I've been told that before or anything.
Recently, it's been frustrating sometimes because I'll like...
I've reached out to places before and they've been like...
They've been like...
Oh, we won't work with you because you're not in a company.
That's what I run into the most, honestly.
But then, you know, like I said, I don't probably get...
Emails for like certain sponsorships or stuff because my numbers are not high.
Or as high as other people, so...
But it is what it is.
Yeah, it kind of sucks.
There was one artist that I really wanted to work with.
Not like for my model or anything.
But just one artist I wanted to work with and they were like...
Sorry, I only work with...
Creators in a company.
And I was like...
Okay.
Thank you.
So...
It is...
It is what it is.
It's okay.
But like I said, I don't...
I'm not like...
It doesn't like get me down or anything.
I'm just kind of just like...
You know.
But I'm not like...
Upset.
Again, I'm not like crying about my numbers or anything like that.
I feel very comfortable and I'm very grateful...
That so many people even...
Found me when I came back, so...
Mental Evil Incorporated.
But like I said, I do...
I do have like a...
A background in my brain goal of 300k by the end of the year.
So we'll see if I get there.
I'll do my best.
I'll try and...
I'll be more entertaining.
And I'll reach out.
And I'll...
I'll do fun stuff.
Burpee thanks for the 5 gifted.
We can do it.
Thank you!
Yeah!
We will do our part.
Yeah, you're already doing it.
You're already here.
You're watching me.
Really appreciate it.
Others might feel the same about you.
I'm not popular enough to collab with Mint.
Well, maybe.
For me, it's not like collabing with people though.
It's more like a...
Like a...
I want...
I want opportunities with the companies.
Like I want to get the sponsorships.
Or the collaborations with the companies.
So...
It's just...
It's like a...
Just one of those things that, you know...
I never...
It's so weird.
Like, I mean, I know I've been...
I've been full-time content creator for a bit now.
But it's still very like...
I'm not a business-minded person.
Usually.
So it's hard for me to kind of like...
Quote-unquote play the business games and stuff.
Get a gamer subs cup made only...
Make it available through...
Danny Mustang, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
So...
Yeah, so I'm not very...
Business-minded.
So it's harder probably for me to...
Get those kinds of offers.
Probably.
That's okay.
One day, hopefully.
Yeah, hopefully one day.
MGS collab.
Gonna be coming to see you...
In two weeks.
Oh, wait, two weeks after my birth...
Wait, it's...
Best birthday gift I could ask for.
Oh, you're coming to the concert?
Thank you!
I was like, wait...
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, so your birthday is two weeks...
After the concert or before the concert?
Do we do like a birthday song at the concert?
What do we say, belated birthday or...
Early birthday?
Coming to see you.
Let's hit up my maid cafe.
In virtual Akihabara.
Prelated birthday.
There we go.
Prelated.
I'm glad that we can give you that for your birthday.
I was gonna say it stopped, but I still hear it.
I'm gonna think I'm gonna open up...
Open up my computer now.
Going to start handing out postcards on the streets like mixed days.
Okay.
I used to do that, actually, when I did some idol activities.
I would stand in Akihabara and I would hand out little things.
Like little handmade flyers and be like, come see my show!
Shale dude!
Sensei!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
So...
Maybe I should do that.
How do I virtually hand out a flyer?
I don't know.
It's kind of why I've been posting...
I've been really annoying, but I've been like posting more...
More pictures on Twitter.
Like, hey, notice my new model.
Come see my streams!
Post an ad.
What kind of ad would I...
Do ads on YouTube work?
When you guys give VTuber ads, do they work for you?
Sometimes I check them out.
Sometimes.
VRChat flyer giveaway.
How do I give away that?
No?
Oh wait, you have ads blocked?
Doki had some?
Really?
I always advertise Mintoshi as my bumper sticker.
Thank you!
Thank you, Squattle...
I got premium now.
Fancy!
Clubs work best for you.
Makes sense, makes sense, makes sense.
Shorts?
Oh yeah, shorts.
Shorts are big, huh?
I'm writing things down.
I can save my money.
I can do shorts.
Actually, I need to get a new shorts editor.
I think my editor is taking a break.
I need to get a new one.
I don't know how to cater my shorts.
Because my shorts are always like...
Shorts for normies.
I hate it.
That's why I never go through the shorts on YouTube.
I always go through them on my TikTok.
Because I've catered my TikTok to me, but...
Oh, vertical streams.
Oh yeah.
Maybe I should do like a vertical karaoke.
Minto, will you ever play Tetri again?
I got an update.
And the new quick play is nice to practice surviving.
It's just climbing floors until you die.
You can only attack people on the same floor.
I don't have any plans anytime soon, but I would never say never.
Yeah, but I don't know how to cater my YouTube shorts to me.
Like, they're always very weird normie stuff.
Like, haha, I'm pulling this prank on my wife.
And it's very clearly like a fake thing.
I don't know how I stop those stupid shorts.
I don't like them.
They're so annoying.
Like, is there a different algorithm, I wonder, for YouTube shorts than there is for...
Than there is for...
YouTube videos.
What's a TikTok I like?
Try not to be scared.
Scariest stories.
I've been almost non-stop listening to those.
Try not to be scared.
Scariest stories.
Have you guys seen those?
They're so funny.
They're so...
They're so stupid.
Tell us one?
Okay, hold on.
It was like...
If they're really stupid, it'll be like...
It'll be like, I sure hope the spooky knife guy isn't in this room.
I'm not in this room.
Said the spooky knife guy, hiding in my closet.
Scary!
Thank you so much for the Akasupa.
I sent Doki my first Akasupa on my birthday a couple days ago to ask her this request.
Now time to ask my other Kamiyoshi the same thing.
What do you mean?
What are some tales you'd be willing to tell us from before you went to heaven?
And we're an itty-bitty streamer.
Any favorite memories?
Favorite memories...
There was one time I was playing Among Us with chat.
And I think there was proximity chat too.
And so I could hear people.
And there was one person that couldn't hear everybody else.
I guess it glitched.
And they were talking to themselves, doing the tasks.
And one of them was just like...
The leaves, where you clean up the leaves.
I still sometimes quote this.
Even though it was so many years ago.
They were trying to do the leaves and we were talking to them.
We were like, hello, can you hear us?
And they were just talking to themselves and they were like, come on, leaves!
Come on, leaves!
Oh my gosh, BHDKillers, you remember!
I remember this.
I think in the moment it was so silly.
Actually, there was another time I thought was so funny.
I collabed with an old friend, Ayane-chan.
And she...
She always had internet issues with me.
And we were playing Keep Talking and Nobody Explodes.
And I was like doing the wires.
Or no, I was doing one part and she told me what to do.
And I was like, okay, Ayane-chan, I'm good.
I'm gonna go to the next thing.
And then she was like...
Release the countdown when there's a 1 in the ending position.
I was like, Ayane-chan, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm on to the wires.
And then it'd be silent.
And then she'd be like, release when there's a 1.
It was so silly.
It was one of my favorite moments that I can think about too.
Yeah, those are fun.
And...
I discovered you back then from collabs?
Really?
Thank you.
One of my core memories I had of a young Minto was you laughing so hard at a kettle saying, ?
and Among Us.
I don't remember that.
I do remember playing Among Us with her though.
Good times.
Simpler times.
But I'm glad that I can still do lots of fun collabs and have lots of fun with people now too.
Yeah, it was fun.
Among Us connects us all.
John, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thanks, Minto.
Also, yes, I consider both you and Doki my Kamiyoshi.
Fan of the following.
Glad.
Thank you.
I remember watching early Minto playing Doom 1.
I'm amazed that she was the first person I've ever seen who played it like it was a horror game.
I gotta play Doom 3.
Really, a real horror game.
What are your favorite moments that haven't happened yet?
Collab with Metal Gear Solid Konami.
What if you make a tickle me wisp?
Have you guys seen that?
Did you guys see that video?
Where someone hooked up the tickle me Elmo to like this volt power supply.
Or sorry, this power supply and then they turned it up to like 15 volts or something and he's just like...
And then he breaks and just goes...
Oh my gosh, I was in tears.
My stomach hurts so much.
Wait, let's... Can we watch it?
Hold on, I'm gonna get it real quick.
Wait, can we watch it real quick?
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to be a react channel, but it's too funny.
You guys, it's too funny for me to not share this with the rest of the world.
Where is it?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, hold on.
I'm gonna change... Sorry, I have my...
I have my Twitter in light mode.
So just to save your eyes, I'll go to dark.
Light mode helps my eyes better, you guys.
If I'm in dark mode, it like actually messes with my eyes.
Okay.
Alright, hold on.
Give me a second.
It's too funny.
It's too funny for me to not share this.
It's not even this person's, like, video, you know, like...
They obviously got it from somewhere too, but I'll still leave their credit since I saw it on here.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Alright, a little tiny watch along, you guys.
It's so funny.
I can't.
Okay, a little tiny watch along.
I think the scream was his motors burning up, so the way his bones are screaming...
Okay, this is so funny.
Okay, here we go.
Hold on.
Concept of Tickle Me Elmo is already so funny.
The way he, like, throws himself back and is just like...
There he goes.
He looks...
The fact is, he's not even smiling.
It feels like torture.
Okay, here it comes.
Here it comes, you guys.
Oh god.
Here it comes.
The way the scream, like, increases...
It doesn't just...
It just sounds more and more pain.
It's so bad.
Oh my god, my stomach hurts.
It's so good.
Oh god.
I bought Phantom Thief tickets days ago.
This is the first Btuber concert I'm going.
I'm happy my first will be with Mint.
I'm excited.
Thank you, Blue Pikmin.
Thank you.
See you there.
He could have really used a turbo button.
Don't even think about using a turbo button.
Can we get Teco Mimento plugged into a wall?
That's all I'm asking.
I gotta go to 15.
Holy moly, my stomach hurts.
It's so good.
Wanted to finish watching the collab, but got paged to work.
Please haunt my employer.
I'll haunt.
I'll possess them.
Even better, I'll possess them and I'll be like...
It's Friday everyday!
That video was really getting me through the day.
Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
It's just the way his head goes...
It's too good.
So funny.
If we get to 300k this year, can we please get a Teco Mimento?
What should we do if I get to 300k?
I've been really bad about all the milestones, huh?
Once you'd be able to play older Ace Combat, I hope you don't get any motion sick.
Old Ace Combat visuals can be weird at times?
Hopefully not.
We'll see.
Chat, request karaoke.
Karaoke is not special.
Wherefore?
It's gotta be more special.
Original song?
I don't know if it would be done in time.
If I were to reach it by the end of the year, you know.
And then... And then if I don't reach it by the end of the year, what do I do?
Just not release it?
VRChat meet and greet?
That could be possible.
VRChat meet and greet, maybe?
30... 300,000 postcards.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm still... Oh, it's actually so bad.
I'm so behind on the Patreon postcards.
I still have a month still to sign.
But I have to do them in such tiny amounts because I think I signed so many postcards within such a short amount of time.
It actually hurts to sign postcards for so long now.
It's so bad.
I feel so awful.
I try to do, like, 50 a day, but it's so... Oh my gosh.
Like, I can't.
I can't do so many now.
I used to be able to just get them out in one huge chunk, but...
It's... I'm like, no, this is so bad.
Mentally or carpal tunnel?
I don't think it's carpal tunnel.
Because, you know, my hand doesn't hurt all the time.
It's only when I'm doing the writing.
So, like, you know, I can use my mouse and everything.
Maybe it's, like, early onset carpal tunnel.
My ectoplasm is getting too stiff.
Oh no.
So I've definitely learned my lesson with the postcards, too.
Like, for future, if I were to ever do something like that in the future.
Also, I feel so awful about all the Patreon stuff from the podcast, because we're so behind.
Just she, Matara and I, we keep getting, like, more things that keep piling on top of us.
And of course I want to stream, but then I also, I'm like, I need to take care of Patreon things as well.
So it's just like...
You're getting old, Minto!
No!
I don't think it's that, because, you know, I had to sign, like...
I signed, like, probably 2,000 cards in, like...
Like, two weeks one time, you know?
Like, I brought two months worth of it to Japan with me.
And I just...
Like, in... Actually, I think it was about...
Well, it was definitely 1,000 in, like, three days.
It was definitely, like, 1,000, because I remember it was when I was in Japan for that really, really long time.
And I kept getting busy, and also going out and doing stuff, and so I wasn't signing postcards.
And then Matara was like, OK, I'm coming.
And I was like, I gotta give these to her.
And I was like, I was in my room, not going outside, just signing postcards the entire day.
Just all day, from when I woke up to night, signing postcards.
To get all 1,000 done in time so I could give them to her.
And it seems like I might have to do the same thing since she's coming over for Thanksgiving.
So, that's so sad.
No, no, no.
It was my fault, first of all, because I should have been doing them little bits at a time, but...
I kept having to move hotels, so I didn't want to...
I didn't want to open them so much.
Where if I moved hotels, they would get damaged, or they would spill, or stuff like that.
So I was like, oh, I'll just do them at my last hotel.
And then by the time I got to my last hotel, I was like...
Oh gosh, I think I'm in trouble.
Death note equals click on live.
Ah, thanks for clicking.
Thanks for joining.
We're done with the death note game though, but it was fun.
You should check it out.
I know it's Thanksgiving, but having you two do an in-person signing stream would be pretty neat.
Maybe.
We were thinking about what we could do.
She wants to play my patchy slot.
So she'll probably do that.
Have you tried a wrist brace?
I have!
I do have one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Always late to everything.
It's okay.
Did month 4 of the postcard ship?
Yes.
I think... I would ask Matara.
She's the one who handles the shipping.
She's the one that handles the shipping.
So I have month 5 and 6 though.
I believe.
Do I cook anything?
Matara says she really wants to try the sweet potato casserole.
I probably will make that.
And I also make the green bean casserole.
Those are my specialties.
Because the green bean casserole is very easy.
And my mom doesn't trust me with anything else.
My mom doesn't trust me with anything.
Did you unblock Matara from Twitter?
X.
Is her subathon over?
Did she finally change her profile picture?
I love how she was like, I'm gonna block you back.
And I was like, haha, I'm winning!
I'm winning!
Alright.
Matara...
Oh, no.
Still...
Still that profile picture.
The clock is at 15 hours?
Oh my gosh, it went up so much.
Good.
I'm going to block you and tell Kojima.
I'll see you when I believe it.
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
Wait, no.
Wait, the other way around.
I'll believe it when...
I'll...
I'll... I'll see it when I... Wait, no.
I'll believe it...
I'll
believe it when I see it.
I'm willing things into existence.
I'll believe it when I...
No, wait a second.
I see it.
I see it when I believe it.
And I'm believing in it right now.
And it appears in front of me.
Irish wristwatch 2.0
Holy cow.
Well...
Mata's been playing a game that I think you'd like.
Oh, she messaged me about it earlier.
The one where it's, like, not Power Wash.
You, like, dismantle a spaceship.
Seems fun.
T-shirt slogan.
I'll believe it when I... No.
I'll see it when I believe it.
And then when people say...
Then when people say, hey, you got your...
I'll believe it when I see it.
No, no.
You can say, I will...
I am the master of my own universe.
I do not let the wheel of fate determine what will happen for me.
I... When I believe it, I will... Wait.
When I see it... No.
When I believe it, I will see it.
I can't get the... I can't get my own saying right now.
I can't get my own saying correct.
See it, believe it, manifest it, make it so.
It's one of those, like...
It's one of those...
Boss... Girl boss...
Slogans, is what you can say.
I'll see it when I believe it.
Datebayo.
Naruto.
Sakura, the beautiful.
Cool.
Motivational quotes.
Ace Combat 7 Top Gun DLC.
I don't know if I actually ever bought it.
Actually, hold on.
I wonder... I have Ace Combat 7 on my old account.
I wonder if it carried over to this one.
Like, if I can play it on this one.
Ace Combat, Skies Unknown.
Oh, I can!
Good.
I can.
If you believe it.
Believe it!
Hi, Cypher.
Ghost Boss, Gaslight, Grave Keep?
That's so good!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm gonna send that to Mataro right now.
Ghost Boss, Gaslight, Grave Keep.
Datebayo.
Mataro said send it.
I love it.
That's so Mataro-coded.
That's so good.
Mataro.
Does Mataro like sweet potato?
Well, she asked for the sweet potato casserole.
I don't think she would have asked for it otherwise.
I just noticed the reflection on the table.
I know, isn't it... I wipe it down everyday.
It's so squeaky clean.
You can see... You can even lick... You can...
You can place your tongue on it, probably.
On the table.
You can lick it clean.
Well, I don't lick it clean.
It's so clean you can lick it.
Ghosts have reflections?
What do you think I am, a vampire?
I'm a ghost, not a vampire.
Completely different.
Do I have a favorite dish for Thanksgiving?
Probably a sweet potato casserole, but I also really love a green bean casserole.
That's why I always mention those.
They're my favorites.
I love green beans, but I hate peas.
But I love green beans.
It's so good.
So yummy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
If you're a ghost, why do you have pointy ears?
Because I'm a ghost.
There's different types of ghosts.
Some ghosts have pointy ears.
I'm like a supernatural paranormal being.
Are you the Shinigami?
No, I'm just a normal ghost.
I'm just a normal ghost.
Don't worry about it.
I'm not Shinigami.
I won't take you.
The spirit of Moe.
Elf ghost?
No, no, no, no.
Regular ghost.
We demand to be called gas sliders.
Who's we?
Who's we, huh?
Who is we?
You're a ghost, eh?
I'll see it when I believe it.
All in favor, say aye.
Why do you always want to be gas sliders?
Why I do my turkey is I brine it overnight.
Then the day, smoke it with my spice blend and herb butter under the skin.
Herb butter sounds awesome.
We are always called gas sliders?
No, you're not.
Well, I mean, sometimes you lie a little bit.
But...
I think...
What do you think about Sadako?
Sadako is fine, but I love Kayako way more.
Kayako-sama is my...
My ghost.
Kayako from Juon.
I'm contractually obligated to shill Project Wingman.
You can fly F-14 and Cute Girls ride with you.
I saw a game.
It's actually on my wish list.
Hold on.
I saw one earlier that I was like, this is so...
Let me get my wish list.
It's called Tiny Combat Arena.
Oh my gosh.
But it looks so cute.
Hold on.
Has anybody played this?
It has very positive reviews.
Hold on.
Hold on, I'm bringing it up.
Has anyone played this before?
Tiny Combat Arena.
It's so cute.
Look at it.
They're like low-poly planes.
And you dogfight.
Look at that.
It actually looks so good even for low-poly.
It's so cute though, right?
I saw it.
It's been on my wish list for a bit.
I haven't grabbed it yet.
The little parachute.
Oh my god, that almost hit the guy in the parachute.
You're a tiny combat arena.
Yeah, I am.
It looks cool though.
I was like, it's just low-poly-aced combat.
Love this.
Yeah, I thought it looked fun.
The price is a little steep.
It's 20 dollars, 20 USD.
Which is why I didn't grab it.
Wait, Microprose Harrier Bundle.
What's that?
Okay, hold on.
But, yeah.
That's why I didn't get it yet.
I was like, it's in early access and it's a little pricey, but...
I usually ignore any games that aren't reviewed by game critics, but that's a personal thing.
But you're gonna miss out on so many things, I feel, right?
If you only stick with the game critics.
You miss out on so many fun indie games and things.
Microsoft Flight Sim Stream for 300k?
We fly all the way to Japan!
I have been meaning to do that.
You spent 300 dollars on 4 cups yesterday.
I didn't think you cared about pricey.
That was a very rare moment of me being...
I'm actually quite frugal, I promise.
Somewhere Nan sneezes.
Nan is here!
Play video games.
Play the video games.
The history about the JPEG dog?
Like how it's the dev's dog?
Hide that Blue Archive account?
I don't spend that much on Blue Archive, what are you talking about?
I spend 10 dollars a month on Blue Archive and that's it.
I spend 10 dollars a month on Blue Archive.
And I actually haven't even been doing that because I've been...
I've been really bad about Blue Archive recently.
You guys, I haven't been playing so much.
I'm a bad sensei.
I'm a bad sensei!
Shiroko Terror is coming, I know!
I got Kirara, she's so cute.
Oh my god, she's so cute.
I want Bunny Toki.
I have regular Toki, I don't have Bunny Toki.
But I got regular Toki like very...
I didn't realize she was a unique unit.
I got her...
Fairly easily, she was like one of my first 3 stars.
She hates her students.
I still trust you with the financials boss.
I promise, I promise I'm not that bad.
Will you ever do a Blue Archive stream?
What about me?
What would I do though?
What would I do?
But also, I play Blue Archive, it's like on my phone, right?
It's like my personal phone.
I guess if I...
If I installed it...
Maybe like...
Maybe if I installed it...
And used my account like on a separate thing.
If I did an emulator...
Would I be able to log into my account?
Or would I have to make a new account?
Because I'm not going to start over.
You can, really?
No, I don't want to mirror my phone screen because like I said, it's my personal phone.
Like, that's why I was like if I put it on like something that I...
That wouldn't accidentally get a notification.
And it's just like, here's your mom's phone number.
I'm like...
Care to share your sensei troubles and gush about your favorite students?
I like Toki and Saori.
And we don't talk about swimsuit Hanako.
I love Koharu, I love Cherino, and I love Hina.
Those are my top three.
Probably in that order even.
My JPEG dog recipes.
Yeah, so sad.
But actually I have to say I like Shimiko too.
Because Shimiko is...
My sister kind of.
Oh and I also love Shiroko because Shiroko is voiced by my seiyuu Oshi.
My seiyuu Kamiyoshi.
Ogura Yui.
Which club would you join?
The game club.
Yeah.
Spend a stream reading Momotalks?
I think I have like 30 Momotalks, I'm not gonna lie.
Let's see.
I'm gonna log in today.
Blue Archive.
Blue Archive!
Just found out a few days ago that they made campaign missions much easier now.
Instead of multiple battles with two squads you can just do one run best kill.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm over a hundred.
I go through them... Oh, I have an update.
I go through them pretty...
Not so often, but often enough I'd say.
Because I like collecting the recollections.
I like seeing the recollections.
Usually after the recollections I always stop.
Unless it's a character I really care about.
Is Blue Archive easy to get into?
I'd say so.
It's not so bad.
Started a couple weeks ago.
I love my starter Hina.
She's so cute, isn't she?
No phone streaming.
Yep.
I won't be.
Idol Mari, Sakurako, and Minai look so cute.
They even have an in-game song.
Won't be in Global for half a year sadly.
Yeah, but honestly half a year is not even so bad...
Compared to some other games that are like crazy.
Yeah, I have all three Hinas too!
Love Hina.
I love Hoshino too.
Hoshino, Shiroko, Hina, Sherry no Koharu.
Yay!
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, Justice Task Force.
Oops.
Arona's Daily.
Oh, I love Arona too.
Three year anniversary stuff.
Oh gosh, I didn't even notice.
It's been a couple days since I've logged in.
What was I logging in for?
Oh, my Momotalks.
Yeah, I have 33.
33.
Not so much.
Koharu...
Speak.
Minto is Arona, Lilac is Plana.
Whoa!
Show yourself to cute games, you goofy ghost.
Stop!
Airborne Ninja, thank you!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the Akatsuba.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
My ojisan is showing.
What other Momotalks do I even have?
Let's see.
Koyuki, Misaki, Momiji, Hasumi, track version.
Ako, dress version.
Ako's dress version...
Her...
Actually, Ako...
Her recollections are so spicy.
Haruna, track version.
Hoshino, swimsuit version.
Ichika, Iroha, Kasumi, Kikyo, Mako, Tomeru.
Renge, Rumi, Wakamo.
Those are the Momotalks I have right now.
I actually just got the temple.
I want to... I want Kirara, but...
I wonder if the temple will last...
Or the temple ticket will last for...
How long does it last for?
When does it expire?
Does it expire before Shiroko Terror?
The ones from mail don't expire.
Oh, just save it then.
My computer is back to doing the normal clicking that it usually does.
It's okay, sort of.
Wait, why are all the stickers in Korean?
What happened?
Oh my gosh.
Blue archive.
Stretch everybody, stretch.
Make sure you stretch.
I'm starting to get sleepy.
Tomorrow will probably be a long, long, long, long, long, long...
Long, long, long, long stream, so...
I should go prepare for that by sleeping.
And looking at my fan.
What's the Minecraft stream?
It's Doki and I playing Minecraft Hardcore until we beat Minecraft Hardcore.
We have to beat it together.
We can't die.
We have to beat the Ender Dragon.
Hardcore style.
So...
We'll see what happens.
Oh gosh.
We'll see how long that takes.
I wanna do some research, like...
So like, this is how you play Minecraft Hardcore if you wanna beat it.
I'm gonna do a tiny bit of research.
I'm looking forward to that stream more than Christmas.
Stop!
I believe in you guys.
Okay, right, snap.
Thank you.
We'll be here for a month.
No!
You start with armor.
Okay.
Let me say something nice.
Stop it.
When you guys are wholesome, I'm not used to it.
Okay.
Thanks for the collab and this fun and cozy Zatsu.
Yeah!
Thanks for hanging out with me while we wound down after that chaotic collab of mind games and brainwaves.
This is fun.
Thank you guys.
Otsumito!
Have a good night.
If I see you tomorrow, I'll see you tomorrow.
If I don't see you tomorrow, I'll see you whenever I see you.
Otsumito!
Itterasshai!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I needed to cleanse the energy today so please accept this.
Thank you Suika!
When you play Ace Combat 7, I will tell you the history.
Yeah!
Thank you!
Otsumito!
Bye bye!
Bye bye, haunt you later.